Hello, howdy howdy, howdy everybody.
Hello, hello, hello.
Wait, one second.
Let me move some window.
There we go.
That should be better.
Howdy, howdy, howdy, howdy, howdy, howdy, everybody.
Welcome in, welcome in.
Welcome back to my cafe.
Welcome to Radio Live.
Right.
Whoa.
A little bit of a spooky game today.
Preparing for October.
Preparing for.
I just felt like I am playing Control Tomorrow, which is
also a bit of a creepy game.
I don't know.
I just like creepy games.
Yeah.
Preparing for that!
We are barely 10 days away too.
Don't say that.
Wait, don't say that because that's also my birthday and I'm
not ready.
Wait, we're more than 10 days from October.
No changes on the schedule?
No, because I remembered why I did control tomorrow and
crime scene are clean up on Sunday.
And it's because...
Tomorrow is a Vex Ball, but I have a meet and greet in
concert, but, uh, I think I'll be okay more to play tomorrow
because Sunday I have Vex Ball meet and greet also, but it's
at 6 a.m.
So, so I was like, I might be so tired.
Well, actually, this morning I woke up at 5 because of
Dronny.
Like maybe it's, I don't know, whatever, it's fine.
But, um...
Danny, welcome to Mambusha, thank you!
Johnny's been waking me up at 5 a.m.
consistently.
For a recommendation for a completely opposite genre, I
would recommend the new super cute game, Wudo.
I saw people playing that.
though.
I don't even know what kind of game it is, though.
Hmm.
But maybe.
Maybe sometime if I feel like playing a super cozy game.
Number go up.
Jihal.
At least he's consistent.
He is consistent.
So, it's happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Congrats on being in Dench Attack!
Thank you!
It's so cool!
I'm in a game, you guys.
I'm in a game.
There's a 6 a.m.
I'm gradually teaching my cats to let me sleep later.
I wish, I wish.
Um, I mean, I get up at, like, seven normal days anyway.
I'm a, I wake up pretty early-ish.
Depends, you know.
I sometimes wake up at seven and then snooze my alarm for,
like, 30 minutes.
But, you know.
I'm in a game!
Um, yeah, I mean, we're, uh, Densatu is in Densh attack.
Um, how does he wake up?
you up by standing on my neck um if you're uh i vicky and
phoebe they both both posted their skin codes i have not
posted mine yet because um i recorded a couple weeks ago and
then uh i had something to do that day and i was just like
i'm so sorry i have to go i'll record the rest later and i
thought that i had more time And then suddenly they were
like, oh yeah, like, we're posting it.
I was like, oh, but I haven't finished my lines yet.
And so I finished my lines like yesterday.
And yeah, so I'm going to wait a little bit until they put
my, finish putting all of my stuff.
I want you guys, if you're going to play bench attack and
have my skin, if you're going to wear my skin.
If you're gonna wear it, I want you to have the full
experience.
So, yeah.
Hello, Minto and I pose like you.
Just got my Fuminto in the mail!
She's such a little cutie.
She is so infant-sized.
She really is.
She really is infant-sized.
Freaky phantom.
Freaky.
V2 bar.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Yeah, my skii.
My skii.
But yeah, so...
That should be out, hopefully, sometime.
Hopefully, sometime.
There's other VTubers as well.
There's Lymu, there's Mousy.
Uh...
Giga.
Uh, I think...
I think...
Uh, Zentrea was also part of our drop, so...
Yeah!
What a freaky phantom.
I can't be any other way.
Oh, yes, Seori.
Hollow Life, Seori.
Yes, yes, yes.
Rin Penrose.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes, yes, yes.
Sorry, there's so many.
Mwah!
Give me a go.
Songs on the tip of your tongue?
You got it?
I know.
You calling me a chicken?
No, I'm playing a scary game today.
Or maybe.
I don't know.
This seems kind of creepy, right?
There's someone missing.
Some kid missing.
There's...
This looks like Duran Duran.
Duran.
Yeah, I don't know so much about this game.
I was told to go in blind.
So I'm excited.
I think we're like, it's one of those.
It's a Firewatch-esque.
If you played Firewatch or watch someone play.
Firewatch-esque.
I think we work a Firewatch.
Congrats on Tensh Attack.
Thank you.
Maybe when you possess people, what does it sound like?
What do you mean?
What does it sound like?
Like.
like do I do they have my voice or hmm hmm it's one of those
easy to spoil ones it seems like it maybe do you have a
whistle in their brain or something is it crunchy I'm
snacking in there I'm like
I don't know I don't know I mean I've never asked anybody
but it feels like when i possess them i just possess i like
i go in and out you know i'm like i possess and then i dip
and the person probably is too like before they realize i'm
even there and gone you know haven't been able to join the
streams as much these past couple of weeks but it was great
seeing you as such an abu the mushi expo thank you for your
turn we had fun at expo oh i will have fun thank you thank
you thank you and if you are well what time is it over there
I heard a vexble might be I heard a lot of people were
waiting in line for so long so hopefully everybody is
midnight hopefully people are getting rest then and ready
for the weekend no four hour lines yeah that's pretty rough
Good luck, everybody.
Good luck, good luck.
Yes, shall we get started?
New game.
I do believe that this is one that we can do in one stream.
So let's do our best.
A one shot.
What do we call the beginning is often the end, and to make
an end is to make a beginning.
The end is where we start from, said somebody.
7 p.m.
Ethan's home.
Snack away the brains fried today.
garlic's at the usual spot so we're at Ethan's house we're
looking Elliot's layer wait I said on the way it said on the
thing age 15 here it says aged 14 oh my gosh he's a Benjamin
button wait what did they get it wrong huh oh wow wait I
turned whoa whoa I had turned the sensitivity up prior to
starting the game because it seemed a little low on
Mia, what's with the music again?
My goal is to talk to Mia.
Rangers reported seeing lights on the ridge near the old
quarry.
Look into.
Old poster maybe.
Maybe, right?
Scout's testimony.
One heard wrestling outside.
around 3 a.m.
neighboring tent sounded like footsteps or someone moving in
the bushes maybe beat us was scared to check and fell asleep
some reported Elliot being quiet didn't talk much Luke
Jenkins oh man Jenkins the story Luke Jenkins 38 robust
build scout leader join in search party evening was normal
campfire marshmallows songs everyone went to tent by 10 p.m.
Elliot seemed quiet little down something was eating at him
Elliot reported to him the quarry what was the what was the
i can't remember what the uh what's it called the monster
was for the quarry game tuesday 8 p.m interview scout leader
luke wednesday 6 p.m check park trail trail closure records
thursday 7 a.m coordinate search party efforts scouts
reported hearing strange sounds coming from the surrounding
caves at night before the disappearance.
Oh, it was a werewolf, wasn't it?
Okay.
No, Wendigo was...
You're thinking of...
You're thinking of Until Dawn.
That was the Wendigo.
Search teams found no substantial evidence.
Elliot left his sleeping bag and personal box inside his
tent.
His backpack is missing, too.
Oh.
No evidence of foul play.
So are we a police officer?
or is this...
What the heck?
I'm like getting so...
You know, when...
Oh, hello?
Was that person driving like a crazy person?
What's our parking job?
Okay.
This is like...
Someone got...
He got so angry.
He was like...
Evening, Minto, did you hear scientists have discovered that
you can milk cockroaches, you know?
of any wouldn't
you like to know yeah raccoon broke into the room little
scoundrel oh mia mia and claire radio tape is
this my i am the ashwood creek police i mean i have a gun i
think i've had enough for today enough gun what does that
mean it's with kcrk ashwood creek radio the search for
Elliot Lair has entered day four.
Elliot went missing during a Boy Scout's camping trip at
Blackwood Camp in Ashley's Great National Park.
His tent was found empty in the morning and there's been no
sign of him since.
Police, rangers, and volunteers have been scouring the area
without any leads.
The weather combined with the rugged terrain has made the
search even more difficult.
The gun on the nightstand is freaking me out.
Any small detail could help.
Our thoughts are with Elliot's family and everyone involved
in the search.
Stay tuned.
We'll bring you any updates as they come.
Play my tune!
Oh, that's the hole.
Alright, Mia.
This is too...
It's too loud.
Please.
I'm trying to think.
I'm trying to work in here.
I'm inspecting...
Oh.
Who dat?
Why is she upside down?
Paper moons.
It's coming from in here.
Oh, come on.
It was a good song.
Dad, do you really have to play this?
What did I put in?
I told you, I'm not calling myself Agent Mia.
Fine.
I'm the dad.
I have to be, you know.
You have to come with me tonight.
I have to be large and in charge.
I don't know.
Fine.
Girl power.
I'll go alone.
Oh my god.
Claw.
Traumatizing.
What the heck are you?
Oh, she's like on a little radio.
What is this?
Sydney's mix.
I'll take that.
What's in?
What's Sydney's mix?
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
The cat is...
Oh wait, this is kind of great.
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
Minto's mix.
Hold on.
Check me out, Mia.
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
Oh, I can't crouch.
Ooh, I can't jump.
Ooh, ah, ooh, ooh, ah.
Look at my shadow.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, da, da, da, come.
This sounds like a song you jazz your size too.
Just come, I said to the plush.
Oh my goodness, you are huge.
I'm sorry for my giant head.
Rico, thank you!
I think they said that, um, what was it?
They said that for all the plushies and stuff.
Or rather, I wanna say something real quick because, uh, if
you go, thank you so much for the fun!
Good day, thank you!
There was like some people online that were like saying, oh
man, I've been waiting for so long for my plushie.
And then, um, And then Setsuna, they went to, they went to,
what's the word?
They went to Moshi Expo.
And, and, and they were, they were selling some plushies,
but some people, a lot of people still hadn't received their
plushies.
And I talked to them about that because I was just like,
hey, I, what's up with this?
Because I'm also a little like, and they said that.
It was a really small amount that they had that was set
aside for like conventions and stuff But there was something
what was it?
Oh They were going to have the The orders for everybody go
out before Moshi Expo But then there was like a heat wave
and it was actually dangerous to work in the warehouse They
were told that they cannot work in the warehouse But, uh,
um, and before that, like, things were really slow because
they had a really small warehouse and, um, and, uh, they
just could not work in it.
So they actually moved to another one recently.
So, more plushies!
What I'm trying to say is, thank you guys so much for your
patience.
Um, more plushies should be out soon, so.
I think, uh, if you're still waiting.
And if you're ever waiting on anything, feel free to email
them.
Of course, of course.
Waiting for my Minto plushie like Fry's Dog from Futurama.
No!
Take your time, I'm not mad because I got the Minto
fingerboard to give me to play with in the meantime.
Thank you.
But yeah, so, oh, so I just wanted to make sure that if you
were waiting on a plushie you were like well they had them
at the con what the heck that that was the answer that was
given to me as well so but um hopefully for future stuff
it's not as long of a as long of a wait a whole stinking
year i'm so sorry what's that oh oh my god what's this wait
what's no what's this Hey, dad, seriously?
Put that down.
Lake on again.
Lake on Friday?
Sydney says you're in.
I've got the tape.
Don't let cop dad kill it.
John.
My cat, Johnny.
Ashwood Creek.
Oh, we're just reading my daughter's like.
Fall 1985, open night.
Thinking about your next step.
Community college.
wow she's going she's going to college i'm just going i'm
hey you're i was once a young girl thinking about college
now i'm dead greetings from lake tahoe mia the work trip's
been great so far i picked this up from a little pawn shop
down the road from the lake half the stuff was junk but i
spotted the radio and instantly thought of you the radio
using maybe you'll pick something pick up something cool in
it or just hear some good music either way I figured you'd
like it I'm back Sunday night sent it to your dad since I
know you're here for the weekend hope you got hope hope it
got there love you mom we're divorced why is it so weird to
spin things around she doesn't care
she's so into this okay let's talk to her you know the whole
block can hear that disco you got going on it's fine dad um
it stays all last time last time I got miss Brooks knocking
on the door saying you woke up her quadruplets you're 18 now
Mia you're an adult now I know she's 18 in this room already
I'm going out with Sydney and John as you know because
you're so nosy no you're not Not with everything going on
lately.
What do you mean everything?
Some kid who got lost in the woods?
You just don't know these days.
Why is she looking at me like that?
There could be a serial killer on the loose.
Come on.
I'll be careful.
Sydney can pick me up.
She's just one year younger than me.
You're not...
Do I be good, good dad, bad dad?
Both are... both are both are both.
You can't go until you...
Why is she looking at me like that?
What is it?
One of the decorations in this room are so funny.
You can't go until you leave the sad cat full-mood
wolf-hawling poster.
You take that off your wall.
Okay, you can go.
Dad of the year, allow me to go out.
Remember, you've got school tomorrow.
Graduation's coming up.
It's Friday, Dad.
Already?
What are you fiddling with that radio for?
I'm trying to find something.
Find what?
I don't know.
I heard some weird sound.
Some weird sound, huh?
Okay.
Goodbye, my daughter.
What else?
Any beer in the fridge left?
The goal is to get a beer.
Oh yeah.
Guys, shut your lids.
Wait, we opened both of them.
This is craziness.
Why would we do that to our daughter?
It's beer o'clock, for real.
I'm gonna try I'm gonna turn the sensitivity down just a
little bit more I don't know why usually games don't make me
motion sick but for some reason this one is zero clock baby
is that me and is that me as a baby me as a baby oh I gotta
put the laundry in okay okay maybe that'll will be our next
chore.
Let's grab the beer then.
No one to call.
So sad.
Local boy is still missing after four day search.
So it's 1985.
Authorities remain baffled in the ongoing search for
14-year-old Elliot Lair, who disappeared from the Boy Scouts
campsite.
Need milk.
I like her sword.
I like our sword.
She drew that yesterday.
Wait, what if I grab milk?
Oh, wait, no.
Wait, wait.
How do I put it back?
Wait, drop it?
No!
Dad, come here!
It's fine, probably.
Today's my birthday, Mr. Shadoway!
Happy birthday!
But because I love the gusto you...
With which you say it, could I get a...
I don't care!
Go, go, go, go, go.
Chug it.
Chug it, Dad.
Go, Dad, go.
What'd you got?
Oh.
Yeah?
See?
You hear that?
It's like...
It's saying something.
It sounds like it's just an interference.
That's what I thought, but I keep hearing these strange...
It's like hissing, you know?
Hiss.
Here, try it.
Hmm.
No, I don't hear it.
Oh, it was just there.
I swear.
You know what, Dad?
Oh, look, you should keep it.
Thanks.
Any chance I can listen to baseball on this?
Yeah, I think it's 90%.
You're welcome.
90.6.
Oh my god, it really is!
What's my next goal?
This one's kind of creepy.
Tune into a hidden signal.
This isn't baseball.
What did I get?
Wait, why is this kind of creepy?
Anyway.
I need another one after that.
just kidding hello 9 p.m.
it was 7 p.m.
you're listening to kcrk ashwood creek radio it seems we
have a new development in the case of missing boy scout
elliot layer park ranger harvey waters has also been
reported missing waters a long-time ranger at ashwood creek
last checked in early this morning his wife says he was
acting strange before his disappearance authorities have
confirmed if the two cases are related with the extensive
how could they not be police are urging visitors to avoid
the park until further notice this is a bright 9 p.m.
the Sun is still up
well anyone else put their hands firmly on the top of wheel
so when they drive oh good course sickness oh Ethan do you
copy are you on scene over oh tab I'm here over yeah I'm
here just arrived over so you had the parking lot yeah still
inside the car over this car should be parked right next to
the road you see it yeah car get out of the car the Ranger
yeah okay
there's so many voices all the time huh I'm inspecting the
duffel bag is it still there oh my god yes yes yes report
Harvey's car it's parked right next to the road so that's
Harvey's car there like they said
yeah and where they who's they security at the parking lot
booth and Ranger team one of them said Harvey had a small
radio on him Wow you
said he's been acting weird oh you said he was acting weird
what did you mean by that who else his car is it because of
the missing kid let me know if the the The audio seems a
little funny.
Sometimes it's really loud.
Sometimes it's not.
Go where do I go?
Well, if you just follow the trail, you should reach the
visitor center.
Get to the visitor center.
Seems fine to do.
Okay, good.
Report the broken light bulb.
A lot of broken glass around here.
Looks like cracked light bulbs.
I think Rangers mentioned some electricity issues.
we got a quarter oh we're gonna get a peppy oh we're gonna
get a peppy oh yeah oh yeah we got a whole it's coming what
does that mean why would you have this in here world's best
security guard
oh interesting phone broken looks like their pay phone's
broken but it was it was There was a dial tone, no?
I'm doomed.
It's coming, it's coming.
All right, what do you guys want?
You guys want a fizzy pop, diet fizzy pop, a peppy, or four
high.
I want the peppy.
Oh, it's only 25 cents!
Oh, yes.
Get a soda from the soda machine.
Drink.
Oh yeah.
That was some good stuff.
Always recycle!
Logs?
Why'd they park like this?
Love me a peppy.
Granite trailhead?
I guess we just go around.
Ah, it makes such a difference.
Though, I...
Did turn the brightness up on this.
Because, you know.
I mean, I could turn it back down.
But I turned it up because, like, it's one of those sliders
that was just, like, slide until you can barely see the
image on the left.
And I could barely see the image on the left when it was all
the way to the max brightness.
So I was like...
parking?
Revoke this man's license.
So, honestly, here, let's see.
Options.
Ooh.
Graphics?
Display?
Brightness.
You see?
It's, like, all the way.
Let's go to, like, 1-5.
Honestly, not that much different.
Mike, India, November, Tango, Oscar.
Sierra, Charlie, Unifor, Tango, Echo, Oscar.
What could it mean?
Stop speaking nonsense.
Is that a person or a really big chicken?
It looks like a chicken man in overalls.
It's a little spooky, guys.
It's, oh, it's a bear.
The wilderness is that way.
This is a nice park!
The North American River Otter!
Hello?
Oh.
I'm at the Visitor Center.
In?
You found anything?
Uh...
It's empty?
It's a ghost town.
Whoa!
Wait, what's going on in here?
Tall tail stuff?
I want to take a moment here.
folks if you've been keeping up with the news you've
probably heard about the search for young elliot lair yeah
14 years old out in blackwood on a camping trip with his
folks and now well no one seems to know where he's gone
we'll read this after now i know this town i know we've been
through tough times before but a missing young boy my heart
goes out to his family and the police officers and park
rangers who've been combing the trails day and i should take
that probably we're Alright, now let's get back to what we
do best here at Ashwood Talks.
Weird stuff.
Ew, on the radio?
Our old friend, the park, and its woods.
Now, you know I love a good mystery.
And the hills out there in the park?
Well, they're not short on stories, that's for sure.
Some folks say they've seen things moving out there.
Things that ain't exactly...
Clamity, thank you!
More, man.
Some of you might have heard about the eyes in the hills.
The poster was about that coming actually but it's been
making the rounds the devs told me oh you defeat full mole
it's coming it's coming sometimes late at night you feel it
something watching you something right behind you when you
turn around there's nothing but that feeling that feeling
stays with you now folks I ain't saying there's something
supernatural out there in the park yeah yeah well you know
how it is with old stories who's gonna be looking at me
through the window all right let's see we've got this thing
which is uh whispering hollows a place of forgotten
mysteries for generations ass ass ass
no lampress welcome to membership thank you so much oh
ashwood Creek National Park has drawn nature lovers,
campers, and hikers to its rugged trails and quiet groves.
But not all are aware of the park's darker folklore.
The stories of those who came to these woods and were never
seen again.
Freudian slip.
I'm always thinking about the Ask Creek.
Paging Dr. Freud.
I know you guys are too.
Don't think you're better than me.
Don't act like you're better than me.
Local legends speak of a reclusive group that once near
what's now known as whispering hollows in the late 1930s
rumors began to spread about strange gatherings deep in the
forest is this gonna be a cult some say these gatherings
were harmless just people looking to live away from
society's gaze but whispers of strange symbols and
unexplained disappearances eventually cast a shadow over the
group what a time to pop into stream
In the early 1940s, they had vanished, leaving only a
handful of vague accounts and curious marks etched on stones
hidden among the remote trails.
Wait, let's uh, report this.
There's little news clipping talking about whispering
hollows.
Is that the little cave next to the lake?
Little cave.
It's a whole cave system that extends thousands of feet
below the park.
Little cave.
The article's talking about some group that used to live
there.
Looks pretty creepy.
Yeah, I think that's bullshit.
Just the kind of folklore that keeps people away from the
woods.
Does that say yeem or you're...
Yeem!
I had to lead it.
Sheeem's for the asswood.
What's this?
Oh, is this him?
Oh yeah, Harvey Waters.
Dang, Harvey, okay.
We got a walkie.
He doesn't have... He didn't bring it.
we've got some first aid kits hopefully we don't need those
oh they got a poster of the kid here yeah they've been
replacing them every other day hoping someone spots him
feels strange being here for Harvey while the whole town's
still out looking for Elliot oh yeah I had to split
resources you just got the short straw you're still part of
this you're not off the case didn't say that his parents
live two blocks away and to look them in the eyes the other
day yeah i know it seems running on caffeine at this point
and we're sorry oh wait oh that was the lady's room i'm so
sorry oh it's too soon four days is too soon to quit yeah
it's too soon tell that to his mom just keep your eyes open
where the heck are we are we pooping in the dark what is
this why am am I reporting something in the toilet report
the dirty toilets here are something else I am a cop yeah
interesting romances in the men's bathroom my god they want
the tea can I have one are we not gonna report on the donuts
breathe in the wild.
Sandmark trails.
Carry out what you carry in.
Yeah, these are all like normal trail things, huh?
See, are you picking up what I'm putting down?
Oh.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, so we're a little dot.
You can see it on the bottom right.
Oh, wow.
This is a big, big park.
There's a map here.
Good.
I got beat.
old one here in my end so it's a piece of crap let's uh
figure out where harvey might have gone yeah ranger said
he's still stuck to his i didn't shut the door did i listen
lakeside trail lookout picnic spot all work checking and if
you left anything behind it'd be in the ranger where's the
cabin where's the cabin on the map should be near the
entrance to granite ridge right beneath sentinel speak right
i'll get going then
It should be, what?
Is it a granite ridge?
Is it the Peely Lodge?
Okay.
Well.
Here we go.
Out until the will- Whee!
What was that?
It's not like a snake just hissed at me!
Oh my gosh, I thought that was a turtle.
Okay.
Here we go, into the park!
Quash and falling trees?
Alright, so we are at the entrance.
What's going on here?
Oh my gosh, everybody's disgusting!
Wait, can I take this flashlight instead?
No?
This is not taking out what you take in.
Wow, nice night, guys.
It is getting a little darker, huh?
A diner?
me a sinner sandwich over there.
Wow, this is really nice.
Game looks good.
Sometimes my...
Sometimes my daughter scared me though.
Look, can you just switch the channel and see what the
situation is?
Alright.
Okay.
This is police investigator Ethan Collins, checking in on
the situation with the search.
This is Luke Jenkins.
Camp leader at the Ashwood Scout Camp.
yeah oh oh tab uh what's the situation update yeah we're
still covering sector four it's rough terrain sir found some
prints earlier but the trail broke off near the stream the
rain you guys think we're gonna find them alive Collins what
are you doing here investigating Harvey's disappearance
figures I talked to him yesterday he was off Snap to me for
nothing.
Kept writing on his notebook.
This game's neat.
You're gonna enjoy it?
I'm like, okay, nope.
I've known Harvey for a long time, but I figured he just
needed space, you know.
Don't blame yourself, Luke.
Focus on the search.
Let the chief know when you're back at the camp.
I won't be on this channel.
Over.
Copy that.
Over and out.
All right, where are we at?
Uh, we're right.
there's a little red dot but the dot does not show the split
in the road that i am seeing now so i'm gonna go up
maybe they maybe they come back together who knows copy that
copy that all right it's like that did
i didn't say When it was happening, but I was like, these
ledges are huge, no?
Like, boat cruises.
Can I...
Is there fall damage?
We're fine.
I give you a kiss.
Gentle.
Don't touch me.
Hmm.
What's this?
Granite Ridge.
Open hiking access.
A legacy of natural wonder.
Hey, guys, a kiss to a be honest.
Woohoo!
Granite Ridge stands as a testament to Ashwood Creek
National Park's enduring history.
Formed millions of years ago through geological processes,
this magnificent ridge bears the mark of time, characterized
by its sturdy granite formations that have weathered the
ages.
Indigenous tribes once regarded granite ridge as sacred
grounds, landscape and bountiful resources ancient artifacts
and petroglyphs discovered in the area testify that to the
deep rooted history and significance it held for these
native cultures and this guy where's the tour wait so now
I'm going down a separate way wait I think maybe this is I
there's a little house on there maybe this is the house they
were talking about right oh no this is boat cruises i give
the ibu who left that chat a kiss gentle everybody be gentle
everybody be gentle explore misty lake Ooh.
Paper moons!
Wait, what, isn't there that one...
Isn't that what it's the...
The Soul Eater?
Stick around.
We've got the weather coming right up.
Isn't the Soul Eater song called Paper Moon?
Paper moons?
What's that sound?
Oh!
Footsteps!
Hello?
Report the report!
Report the footsteps!
Black paper mullin Yeah Hello I'm inside the staff room at
the boat house Floor is a mess Got muddy prints Looks recent
Looks like they go straight to the window It's cracked open
A bit of mud on the frame Could be how someone got in No no
Doesn't make sense Yeah But doesn't make sense Yeah If they
walked backwards Meow meow meow Meow Miam, miam, miam,
miam.
What is this?
His walkie's busted.
Covered in mud.
Yeah, busted radio.
Back's all smashed.
At the boat house.
Well, no wonder this search party couldn't get a hold of
him.
It's making this weird sound.
Almost like it's hissing.
Could just be interference.
I'm even surprised we got reception, to be honest.
Especially with electronics going haywire in the park
recently.
Can't have had much luck calling for help.
The hiss, the hiss.
oh my god is this his family holy cow i don't i think maybe
we should run our photos through different filters before we
print them out found harvey's jacket he's definitely been
here it's all covered in mud what's with all the mud sounds
like he took a swim in swamp maybe he did you don't get
covered like this in a lake doesn't look accidental either
Maybe he was looking for something.
Yeah.
Take some matches.
Explorers, Harvey, and David.
Drama.
Got a couple of family photos.
Do we have any statements from them?
More broken glass?
If you report his demon family.
Reminds me of Sokolov's wife and Sokolov's family photo.
Another broken bulb.
Is that not suspicious?
Hmm.
An arrow pointing to there?
What does it mean?
Oh, I think it means that's the exit.
What is...
Is this the thing that's...
Something is, like, static-y.
Terrible.
Can I go swimming?
before you board here I go oh be
urban oh my god somebody's shoe we got something here Rob
looks like it's a shoe near the waterline too small to be
harvest a shoe what's the condition muddy waterlogged been
here a while uh-oh Elliot had sneakers on right what they
look like uh it's a sneaker all right white or it used to be
brands deluxe stars no it's be urban just below the boat
house near the water line tracks end here though how did it
end up in the water
the window it's a bit muddy so is the window inside the boat
house you think someone threw it out and then it washed back
ashore thank you dude on the radio said it was a sneaker
before he knew what it was well maybe he was saying that
Elliot was wearing sneakers right we're not gonna report on
the the boat the capsized boat oh my god I thought this was
a body I thought this was hair and this was the body and
their little legs oh my god I had a jump scare holy let me
just go flashlight on unstable ground oh that's why we
couldn't walk we found Elliot where am I anyway oh my god
this would be the perfect place to you guys ever be
fascinated in like bog bodies and stuff it's so interesting
I thought I heard a whi- I
do hear a whispering you guys hear that
those are cool aren't they what's a bog body Minto basically
you know long long long long ago uh you know if like some
people lived close to marshes and bogs and stuff they would
bury their dead in the bog but because of like the you know
the the state of the you know how the bog was it would
essentially preserve the body making them kind of mummified
we didn't come from this way right No.
We came from the other way.
Yeah, bog mummies.
It's pretty freaky.
Bogs are low oxygen environments so the bodies mummify.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Thanks for explaining it way better than me.
I couldn't remember entirely the science behind it.
I don't think these types of trash cans are very good for
parks, right?
Because animals get into them very easily.
so if you look them up like some of them look near like
they're just napping reminds me the convo about the bury me
bury me meme with matara let me start learning this song on
my guitar
aloha binto aloha
i saw it oh there's a fallen tree in the way I can't.
Not this one.
It's too big.
Is it too big?
You gotta work in yourself, man.
Yeah, fuck you.
I'm finding a different trail.
I am?
Uh, can I go through here?
This is not natural either.
Who did that?
Wait, I saw it on the map.
We should be able to go to the right here.
But...
Oh wait, yes we can.
Yes we can.
There we go.
It's a little dark.
Hmm.
Mince ploby.
Hey.
Like these le- Oh, I was about to say these ledges are
crazy.
He's just jumping off of them.
What are you saying?
You're going to get back up there?
What are you going to do now?
What's rumbling?
More footsteps.
in the mud similar to the ones in the boat house yeah about
the same they look pretty fresh mud's not dried out yet
these prints are deeper than most looks like whoever made
them was wearing boots not regular shoes those are the same
prints in Harvey's room mm-hmm sounds like we're on his
trail what was that something's creaking next to me the
trees are great my shoes are soaking wet oh boohoo uh I'm
kind of like going a strange way now huh
oh I'm going down the creek I shouldn't be doing that I
don't think at least what I'm getting lost in the sauce okay
we what what Okay, screw it.
I am gonna raise the brightness.
We'll go to Lake 2.
I need to be able to see.
You can zoom in on the map.
Yeah, but I can't zoom in on life.
I think I have to go through that for through the creek.
Ooh, they look like fingers.
Maybe they are.
What's over here?
Sentinel's lookout.
Found part of a trail sign.
Swimming in the mud.
Sentinel's lookout ring a bell.
Figures.
What?
You're on the old trail.
Because nobody bothered cleaning up the signs.
Should have just climbed over the tree.
Yeah, Bozo.
So this is the old trail?
I mean, we're still on it.
What was it?
Oh my god.
this sounded like a moose that's our real that's the real
horror a moose in these games hello
okay we're on the right path
hello what is this i've got some tree carvings they're
strange at least looks like some ancient Ancient symbols or
something.
Ancient symbols, guys.
We should consider binocular, microscope, telescope keeping
it alive.
Looks like some of these could be related to that old group
that used to live here.
Ancient symbol.
Yeah, I'm sure they dig that kind of folklore.
Hmm.
Whatever could this one be?
1984 was not an instruction manual.
M plus K.
Ash.
Ashwood.
High.
Seniors 83.
Courtney, she goes a bitch.
Yeah, screw Courtney.
The ancient symbols.
What could they mean?
Actually, they are different colors than that one.
So, like, maybe this is the ancient symbol.
Right?
The other symbols are also ancient.
Yeah.
Screw you.
Courtney!
Screw you, Courtney.
Courtney knows what she did.
Well, how old is this ancient path that we're on anyway,
huh?
Do I go through this?
Fuck!
You can fuck off, Mother Nature.
Language!
It's a bird.
I had a feeling some sort of jump scare was about to happen.
Oh, service shed.
Locked.
Somebody was at the picnic area tonight.
Looks like they even wanted to stay for the night.
It's got to be those teenagers again.
Considering recent events, why would anyone want to camp out
here?
I think for these guys, it just became way more interesting
to camp there.
Ah.
They left their boombox here.
Consider it.
I heard the wildlife around here really like some punk
music.
Yeah, but are we not going to worry about what happened to
these guys?
Somebody left their backpack here.
Their backpacks are here.
Looks like they left in a hurry.
Yeah.
Should I leave it here?
Well, until you find Harvey, yeah.
Got a can of Dr. Almond.
Dr. Almond, the Paging Dr. Almond.
Good luck, sir.
I've been Mardsabon.
Great.
weird taste.
I thought they stopped making these.
Yeah, that's what I thought.
They brought no food.
They only brought lots of drinks.
Whoever announces almond like that.
Dr. Almond.
Maybe we've all been saying it wrong.
The guy who invented the almond is named Almond.
And he's just like, ah.
In the future, everyone will remember my name.
They'll all say it.
Almond!
And now we just say, Almond.
They got a fire going and everything.
You think Harvey could have gone after them?
Yeah, maybe.
Keep an eye out.
Hmm.
Almond!
I'll remember you, Al.
Wait, this is even really beat up, no?
Can I take your tape?
Have you been playing long?
Should I wait for the VOD?
about an hour but it's i think it's okay up to you honestly
you haven't i don't think you've missed much i wish i think
the one thing this game needs is like a compass because i
don't know if i'm looking you know i don't know if i'm
looking which way what way you know what i mean
oh okay this is the okay Imagine the pain of Dr. D's.
Yeah, honestly, even though we've been playing for a while,
not too much has happened.
So, trail is closed.
Wait, do I...
Whoa.
I feel like I hear whispers again.
Oh, my God.
What is this?
What is it that suddenly made you believe in God?
Something's called a blocked trail.
I'm Mr. Allman, but you're just calling me out.
main trail some trees have fallen to lynch light fuck looks
like it uh-oh ah no it's this what the hell what is
happening the toolbox on the tables on a different frequency
now i think it's aliens guys it's aliens it's aliens it's
aliens not much It's aliens.
Yeah, yeah.
Hey, you got that little radio.
So you can tune into that frequency to clear up the sound.
You mean my radio?
Yeah.
Right.
Okay.
Whatever frequencies on the boombox.
Did it just say cracker?
I think a bird has taken over the, uh...
It says cracker.
A bird has taken over the boombox.
A bird is on the frequency.
Hold on, I'm going to walk away from it a little bit.
I just tuned into the frequency.
And what did you hear?
I managed to clear up the sound to hear the signal, and I
heard the voice.
All right, that's odd.
Could be interference, or maybe someone messed up with an
open frequency.
Anything else?
No, just a whole load of nothing.
in a boom box that shouldn't be working.
Okay, I'll log it.
Probably some random shit anyway.
Tired brains start filling in gaps.
Right.
We're not gonna mention how, when it said that, the door
flung open.
We have a hatchet!
Oh, I thought something was gonna be standing there.
I thought something was gonna be standing there!
Do you guys see anything?
Harvey!
Harvey, don't you want to come out?
I'm too weak to get a fence.
Gosh, the running in this game is so slow.
Like, this is the walking.
And this is the running.
Kind of insane.
Can I...
Why is it made of steel?
Maybe there's something at the landslide instead we can get
it.
That's criminally... Like, this is walking.
Realistic?
For a grandpa, maybe!
Um... Oh, wait!
Oh, over here, over here.
Oh, awesome, awesome, awesome.
Ha-cha!
I sound like I'm using a lightsaber.
I got an achievement for clear in the bush.
I and CJ, thank you!
Oh wait, oh wait, oh wait.
Last man said he, thank you!
You're running, I thought you were walking.
No, I've been running this whole time!
Even with like the...
This is it.
Even like if you think it's like a heavy thing, no.
This has been it the entire time.
Ah!
What?
Did I?
What the
heck was that?
Ah yeah!
You missed it?
It was so fast.
It was so...
Oh wow.
Okay.
excited oh my oh me oh my oh yeah are we not gonna report
that or mothman is in my way
okay we just keep going i guess
don't look him in the eye
sorry i've been recording a lot recently so my throat is
quite sore actually
Is that a bear?
Err.
We might be in trouble.
We are going to the Ranger's cabin.
That's what we were trying to do, no?
So we can...
Let's go that way.
Let's go to Ranger's cabin.
Actually, well, Sentinel's lookout is only one thing, so
we'll go this way first.
And I think also...
Well, it's kind of on the way anyway, no?
Uh-uh.
from all the vaing from last stream my throat was even
before then yeah my throat was so sore afterwards the
wetlands this is where we went to no this is where we came
from yeah we've been there before oh wow what a nice little
lookout point wow do we have to go looking for him at night
or the view is clear from here just miles of trees all the
way to the horizon you know this place is to freak me out as
a kid the park yeah not the bears or the dark or any of that
is it the pyramids oh listen I know this search is getting
to everyone but you've been off again lately uh-huh don't
start I'm not just saying you want to talk
copy that oh dang I was trying to go a shortcut I hear like
some weird sound oh it sounds like someone logging someone's
chopping wood you mean to tell me somebody's chopping wood
in the middle of the night where even are you just below the
lookout I think it's stopped now oh what the fuck
I think we need more than like two people on this part, you
know?
Like on this...
Maybe I shouldn't have gone alone.
Oh, the wind just disappeared.
It got really quiet.
Oh, wait, uh...
Yeah, we need at least three people.
So true.
Ranger cabin.
Sorry.
Again, I'm getting a little, like, topsy-turvy.
Okay, so if we went up this way, it's just around, let me
see though, the sound was...
I don't think there's probably...
Well, I don't know, it doesn't hurt to look and see if
there's something over here, right?
Yeah, whatever happened to the body system!
We're such fools!
Okay, I don't think there's anything over here, actually.
I'm confused.
Why aren't we... they using a bloodhound to find the missing
person?
you but I'm a dog I'm half man half dog oh yeah here it is
oh we're not reporting this okay sure yeah let's go to the
cabin dog man or man dog does that determine which side is
which side is which thank you for the dog wait we can jump
this this is definitely not too big is it this isn't
oh it's paint it's paint I've got blood whoa whoa whoa what
there's a rock covered in blood looks pretty fresh parts if
it dried out yeah positive could be animal can't say exactly
where are you right now just outside the cabin copy that we
need to get you back up yeah again everyone's out in the
search party I'll try something I'll stay here and look for
more clues or you're mad with the spot if you can I mean why
not two birds with one stone we search for man and we search
for kid Why not both?
Why me alone?
Alone!
Why are there so many down trees?
What the?
Oh, okay.
Someone be cooking in the cabin.
A candlelight dinner?
Were they waiting for me or something?
Oh my god.
Wait.
What if this was a setup?
Wait, they were like, this is the only way, actually,
everyone's fine.
There is not even an Ethan kid.
Ethan's, there are no kids named Ethan.
There never has been.
We made it up.
I just got you here so that we could get you a little, uh,
you know.
Oh, wait.
I'm at the cabin, but the door is locked.
You see anyone inside?
Looks like someone's just been here.
smoke's coming out the chimney Harvey why would Harvey leave
the place like this let didn't hear anyone search party
should be at the surprise party what do you mean nothing I
heard Shia LaBeouf works no I didn't hear anyone search
party should be at the camp I know they like boarded up the
thing too let me try let me try search party this is police
investigator Ethan Collins come in anyone out there Luke
Jenkins officer Carter nothing it's dead air this isn't
normal they always check in every hour yeah it's fucking not
look I gotta get inside to investigate okay there should be
a spare key somewhere might be hard to find it where's the
key where's the key look for a stone with red I'll find the
way in a stone with red marking the one with the blood on it
Is that all that it was?
Stone with red marking.
So it was the stone to hide the key after all.
Here's a meadow.
Read Ranger's Journal.
Oh.
Situation board.
There is no situation...
Dear figure.
Oh, I took it?
My bad.
$11 walkie.
What a steal.
Okay, I don't like that.
Where's his diary?
Oh, here we go.
Yoink, my dear toy now.
Morning shift.
Oh, wait.
August 23rd, 1985.
Name Tom Blake.
Morning shift.
Check the perimeter of Missy Lake.
Some campers stayed at the night uh cleared debris from the
main trail leading to granite ridge another black bear
spotted near the cave entrance warned nearby hikers and
posted caution signs afternoon shift routine check on peely
lodge all clear minor maintenance required on the cabins
notice some unusual radio interference while communicating
with hq likely due to the storm last night it's aliens It's
got to be aliens.
You shouldn't have touched that deer.
Probably cursed.
Wouldn't be my first curse, though.
I'm collecting them.
Infinity stone curse.
Glove.
August 24th, Suzanne.
Morning shift conducted a safety briefing for new Rangers.
Patroled the lower Granite Ridge trails.
No incidents.
Found remnants of an old campfire near WH area.
Cleaned up and posted.
No campfire signs.
After noon shift, met with local wildfire.
Researchers shared recent bear sightings.
Reported a falling tree.
Fallen tree blocked blocking the main road near the
entrance.
Maintenance team scheduled for clearing tomorrow.
Observed increased tourist activity around Missy Lake,
requesting an additional trail check tomorrow.
The Almundians.
The curse glove.
yeah i'll be able to like throw throw some sort of finger
sign i'll be like naruto naruto summoning my curses jujutsu
summoning them august 25th michael hopper morning shift
routine patrol missy trail nothing unusual afternoon shift
notice strange carvings on trees near the south trail
possible pranksters weather report indicates potential
storms tonight advised campers to prepare
August 26th.
Oh, Harvey!
Morning shift cleared fallen branches along the Granite
Ridge Trail, assisted hikers looking for an old watchtower.
Trailhead advised against going off route.
That's ghost aliens.
Afternoon shift.
Found an empty fire pit near the creek, not marked on the
map, left a warning notice.
Radio interference was minimal today, spotted deer near the
water.
First time in a while.
Harvey.
Morning shift.
Notice increased noise in the radio static again, mostly
near whispering hollows.
Hydration check.
Thank you, skeptic.
I just took a sipie, but I'll take another one.
Afternoon shift.
Heard laughter deep in the woods during patrol.
Could have been campers.
Nothing on file.
Tom Blake Morning Shift Assisted a lost hiker back to the
visitor center Provided them with a new map and safety tips
Afternoon Shift Notice stone carvings in GR entrance Visited
Peely Lodge No Issues reported Yeah I think WH must be
Whispering hollows right?
Sometimes they Write it out, sometimes they don't Michael
Morning Shift Boy Scouts requested with tutoring went on a
short instructional hike with one scout team found strange
footprints near foster quarry afternoon shift winds very
calm tonight compass spinning wildly near certain areas this
is gotta be okay gdr granite ridge w h white house oh no
whispering hollows ml misty lake i i think it's aliens
Harvey W.
Morning shift.
Heat wave has arrived.
Went on a hike with Boy Scouts at Blackwood Camp.
It was hard to breathe today.
Afternoon shift.
The forest feels alive.
Not in a good way.
The shadows move when I'm not looking.
He was there.
We couldn't find him.
I don't remember leaving.
Harvey.
Morning shift.
My flashlight flickers when near the cliffside.
It's annoying.
I don't remember leaving.
After noon shift, the teens again.
They ran when I called out.
Same faces, still 13.
The door to the ranger cabin was locked, which is odd since
I had left it open.
I swear I saw shadows moving.
They disappeared when I shined my flashlight on them.
Harvey, morning shift.
Remaining fallen trees removed by maintenance teams.
After noon shift.
The forest is unnaturally silent.
Almost windless today.
No animal sidings.
Sat down to right this entry.
The shadows are closer now.
there were two moons tonight i felt his breath again harvey
the fire look into the fire found a ranger journal inside
the cabin most entries seem routine it's it's off now trail
maintenance wildlife logs they get weirder especially
harvey's logs since the day elliot went missing moon's lucky
guy come on piece of shit i should go outside uh-oh uh Are
we not gonna cut what the hell
I think the door just locked What is this What the hell?
What I there's a Can you speak god damn it?
It's the wall There's writings on the wall.
They're numbers?
The numbers.
What?
I don't know what the hell's going on.
I can't fucking...
Robert, I'm fucking locked in the cabin.
Yes!
Fuck this!
Salmon!
He's got a fish under the bed.
Uh...
Wait a bit.
These photos are so funny.
Oh, maybe that?
No.
Can I lock go leave now?
91.
Look at the fire.
Uh.
Maybe I can leave through the window.
No?
No.
Um.
Look into the fire.
Can I like actually go in?
Oh,
yeah, I forgot we had the axe.
No?
Oh!
What's up with the window?
Isn't that just...
Wait, what?
What?
That's weird!
I know the metal wooden doors.
What the heck?
Ghost of glass, for real.
Is there something else to look at or...
Sorry, ouch.
No, this is... that's annoying.
Um, I don't think anything has changed.
91 with a typewriter.
Oh, good idea.
Good idea.
Or maybe my radio.
Wait, hold on.
I think it's my radio frequency.
Actually, now I think about it.
Dude, dude.
Here.
Dude.
Who are you?
Echo Beach.
Two.
hurts beach echo stop sound painful repeat what sound what
sound how do i stop it police turn back turn now echo beach
echo go beach
echo that was insane there's got to be an explanation for
this hello rob god damn it please tell me you can fucking
hear me great well i'm just telling you i'm getting out of
here now oh my goal is to leave okay oh i'm scared i'm
scared i keep hearing something you guys hear that
Someone's waiting for me on the b-ball court
He's gonna chase me
Shia LaBeouf Running for your life From Shia LaBeouf He's
brandishing an axe Shia LaBeouf
Oh, hello, sir How's it going?
Oh, why would we say anything?
Are we okay?
You're no No it's not you are you harvey waters sir what you
doing out here can't you see chopping wood helps me think no
what are you doing here your wife's worried sick I was sent
to find you she doesn't understand none of you do why would
you what's your name well just why would you say why Ethan
Collins I'm with Ashwood Creek PD you again what what no it
must have been someone else you know what it's like to lose
someone to lose track of them and search for them every day
I know he's out there I've seen him is this about the boy is
this about Elliot you know anything about the boy Elliot
he's a scout good kid yeah you'll never find Why?
Well, yeah, what do you know?
Why is that?
Don't...
We've seen him.
He shouldn't have gone in there.
In the cave?
It's not my fault.
Okay.
Did he go in the cave?
All right.
Okay.
Where's the boy, Harvey?
You know, right?
In the circle.
He's already part of it.
Just like the others.
You can't save him now, Ethan.
You'll understand soon enough.
Teenagers at the picnic site.
Why were you angry this morning?
Yeah, why were you?
What were you upset about?
You came here this morning, angry.
This morning?
Yes, why, Harvey?
What happened to you?
There is no escape.
Harvey, I need you to calm down.
He's an Enderman!
Come with me.
You have to come with me now!
We can find him!
We can get down on the ground!
Ah!
Why?
He was just telling me!
Oh my god.
Ah!
Oh my god, oh my god.
So loud.
I told you these ledges were too damn high.
Man in the woods, meet Harvey.
Are you scared?
Girl?
10 p.m.
It's only been like one hour?
Are we for real?
Do you copy?
I repeat, do you copy?
Yeah.
I'm here.
Jesus.
You sound grumpy like usual.
Oh!
Making happen.
I am.
Fuck my leg.
I just took, like, a 30 feet fall and ended up...
God knows where.
You what?
You're not serious.
Uh, I hurt my leg!
I think I fucked up my leg.
I'm not zoomed in.
Oh, I was zoomed in.
I think I was actually...
accidentally holding it Jesus he was just hacking away at
this tree stump over and over like he didn't even know I was
there yeah he wasn't the turned around and looked right at
me I swear to God Rob he wasn't there I was running away
from him and slipped and Harvey say anything at all he knows
something I think he something about the missing boy more
than anyone else the way he looked at me when he mentioned
there was no escape no idea I feel like the guy on the other
side is Rob is not taking me very seriously okay I'm on it I
don't think he's taking me very seriously oh my gosh doesn't
that look like I thought it was a shadow of a person like
the outline right there bodacious bod yeah he and also we
finally answer we don't know how long we were out for right
and he just kind of is just like aloha aloha are you gonna
answer me la-di-da like sorry i was let's see we don't know
yet we don't know he was so rude
Um, this is a pathway.
Something's rumbling, though.
Something do be rumbling.
Huh.
We got rumbles and we got creepy music?
Let's go towards the rumbles, I suppose.
Oh.
Oh, and we got a scary tree.
Oh gosh, it just gets worse.
uh-huh uh oh I found it I found a thing we shall transcend
oh great this looks totally not creepy what is it got a rock
here prominently placed symbols carved into it symbols yeah
it's a snake this one's weird it's It's like a snake eating
its tail.
The Ouroboros!
Sounds like the Ouroboros.
It's a mythology thing.
What does that mean?
It means snake eating its tail.
It means he's a butt eater.
Snake eater.
Harvey mentions cycles.
Oh.
Uh...
It's where Elliot?
He said Elliot was in the circle.
Yeah, you did say that.
Yeah.
Whatever that is, it's our key to fighting.
Best way.
So, aliens, and or cult, and or ghost?
Actually, I don't think ghosts are a part of this one.
Dang, we're doing a lot of jumping for a guy who hurt his
leg.
What a thrill.
Exactly.
Spooky Minto in the strolls through the spooky woods.
What more could you ask?
through the oh they took his eyes I got a dead deer here
pretty far gone to find far gone rotting rotting rib cage is
showing you smells fucking awful it's been here a while well
no it's just here yeah it's kind of hard to say if there's
bite marks it's like decaying so yeah that's we don't want
our we don't want any campers seeing this that's a little
that's pretty disturbing you remember the missing person
case from a decade ago it was up there in the park too
vaguely that was I wasn't on the case one of them was
Harvey's brother his name was David they never found him or
any of the answers That seems pretty important information.
You think his and Elliot's case are connected?
I mean, it's a long just focus in on what we've got on
Elliot.
This seems like a good...
Hey, hey, I'm by a fence and I see a trash can...
I see something up there.
I see a fence!
This seems kind of important.
This seems like a good landmark, maybe.
No?
You took the toy.
This one's on you.
you.
No, no, no.
Wait, maybe we can go up there.
Thought those were bones.
Oh, come on.
No, come on.
No, no, no.
Triangulate my location.
Be me.
Okay.
We're going down, but we're not going back up.
I don't think.
La la la la.
I don't know how to get home.
Thank you so much.
For 29 months.
Thank you.
Welcome back.
What are you looking for?
I think our goal was still to...
Oh, it's just find our location.
So honestly, I have no idea what we're looking for.
Oh.
That's a rock.
We're looking for anything maybe?
I'm just walking.
point.
I feel a little aimless.
A little aimless.
Minto cute?
Why are we biting me?
Manners!
You guys need to get it together!
Minko in the woods.
That's me.
Area closed.
Can we not report this?
Hi, I'm by a closed area!
What?
Where the heck are...
Oh, wait.
I feel like I'm playing like some sort of farm simulator
when I start clearing these, you know?
I found a really weird sign here.
Area closed by the U.S.
government?
What?
Shit, you're at that sealed off zone.
They cleared out years back.
I thought that was just a rumor.
Stop biting me!
Did they find it?
You ever hear what really went down here?
Yeah.
Oh, they never told us.
Uh, should I go past the sign?
Aliens.
Well, if you want to get out of there...
Stranger things?
Wait, if I want to get out of here...
Okay.
Wait, what does that mean?
Find your location...
Does this not tell you enough?
Someone's been chewing here.
And it wasn't me.
Okay, dead end.
No, I'm on air.
What is wrong with you all?
Oh.
You guys were in this...
I'm lost in the woods and you just almost are biting me.
Spooky tree.
oh i thought that okay hold on does anyone else see
i see like a mouse like a rat standing up with a with like
either all not i didn't see a hulu i see a hulu hoop now but
at first i saw like a little like uh like a a walking stick
and a top hat Seen, I'm Hades.
Please turn it around.
Hello, my baby.
Hello, my darling.
Hello, my...
Running from your life from Minfantum.
Brandishing a knife, it's Minfantum.
Looking in the shadows.
Feet the bird, superstar, Minfantum.
Google delicious Minfantum recipe, please.
There is none!
The serpent returns.
The forest is awake again.
We shall meet again and finish the vision of Victor Thorne.
I found this letter in some wooden box inside a tree here.
The serpent returns.
The forest is awake again.
We shall meet again and finish the vision of Victor Thorne.
Anyone knows a Victor?
Any idea who Victor Thorne is?
Who knows?
Got Friday and Tuesday.
I think Rob knows something.
We got Friday and Tuesday.
Screw it, bonch bonch, canon ballism, yum.
That's, it wasn't even me, Vinky emergency food.
This is so rude.
You guys can't even eat me.
I am a ghost.
What are you, what are you, what are you?
You're going after, ectoplasm after goo?
I found an old tent out here.
Military or federal.
They left stuff out here, but it looks abandoned.
Of course they did, and they didn't tell us shit.
I won't bite you, Mito.
Maybe.
You do look tasty.
The meat chocolate is a lie.
It's a lie.
BAMP!
A4 in the search for...
Alright.
Mr. George Lake, special agent.
Senior Director for Intelligence Programs.
Sweet 30 redacted!
All agents stationed.
Ugh, I can't read it.
Wait, what, wait, what just happened with it?
Wait, do I have an inventory?
Oh, I do, I do, okay.
Documents.
Federal report.
Here we go.
To all agents stationed to assist with Operation Black
River, after the collapse of Black River, the site was
deemed unstable.
Further exploration prohibited.
All operations are halted starting today.
The FBC has been here.
Oh my god, my games are starting to...
Oh, I got a wood blank.
Oh, I got multiple.
My games are starting to collide.
I'm taking.
Do not cross.
Or...
It says, do not cross, or...
Scorkton.
Field site 12.
Radiation level is consistent with projections.
interference with comms confirmed multiple anomalies
detected strongest point seems to be below the depth of
current site I'll take one for the team it offered to be
bitten by a mutant oh okay Murina come here sorry though I
have a fang so I might feel a little extra sharp thanks for
the QR thank you thank you civilians redacted claim to have
seen a strong light prior to subject disappearance recommend
immediate cessation cessation cessation cessation of public
access and containment of vector any and every document
related to operation Black River is classified and should be
withheld from local law enforcement well good job you had
one job they left behind a clipboard looks like one of the
first reports anything interesting in there They took some
measurements.
I'm gonna have to wait the first time.
Let's go.
Anomaly.
Mentions of some type of an anomaly and comms interference.
Maybe we need a bite and greet.
Screens are similar to what just happened to me.
Can't spell anomaly without nom.
Why is this getting so derailed?
Are you guys not thoroughly entertained by the game?
Oh, oh.
Wait, look how cute these are.
This is so cute.
It's so anime.
Cute cards.
We're still lost.
What about a little nibble?
It was my B-Day!
Can Grumpy Happy Birthday!
I don't know, I've never heard of a...
I've heard of birthday punches, not birthday nibbles.
This looks...
What is going on?
We're not gonna report this?
Okay, yeah.
Place?
Missing object.
I'm in the middle of a stone circle.
What?
This looks like my sister's house.
I can insert something into the stone here.
What do you mean insert something?
How do you insert something into a stone?
Pretty easily.
It looks like there is a shape.
You got anything?
Should I do it?
Should I even do it?
Who knows what will happen?
I don't know how many of you.
Sounds catchy, but we're on our way to get you out of there.
You don't even know where I am!
We're not gonna report this really mysterious and suspicious
gate?
Oh my gosh.
Intertained but just a little hungry too.
You guys need to eat before stream.
What hour 4519 actual?
You can bite if you want.
You can bite if you want to.
You can leave my bones behind.
But if your friends don't bite, and if they don't bite,
they're no friends of mine.
Tim Tim, thank you so much for the five gifted.
I'm remembering a different version of this song.
Where did I come from?
Oh, I came from over there, so let's go this way.
No one's gonna mess with me.
I got my axe out.
Oh, there's a light here.
Wait, is this the cave that we should not be going into?
There's a cave opening here.
I think I hear a faint noise from inside.
Cave opening?
I wouldn't go there, Ethan.
You think whatever the feds were investigating could be in
here?
Just be careful.
I eat before stream when there's a perfectly delicious Minto
right there.
again the the mint chocolate it's it's a lie it's it's an
illusion it's like trying to eat a cloud
should we be in here guys I don't know if I should be in
here look at me standing look at my silhouette it's so
intimidating I just my everybody everybody holds their axes
up like this right and phantom interactive bite experience
brought to you by oh she spark you ask them not me so zero
calorie ice cream perfect no maybe i don't know how going
deeper into the mines in which in which they are blocked off
is going to help us get to
getting picked up faster was this a loop I think so why are
we going deep we're in
I hear whispering
what the fuck Rob I found a cavern here I saw eyes in the
dark and there was some kind of a movement.
Strawberry flavor.
No, I'm not losing it.
I'm not losing it, okay?
Why is he not taking me seriously?
Vampires?
Yeah, what if it's the- what if we're saying aliens and
ghosts, but it's- Oh my god.
It disappeared from here.
Is that a fucking totem?
I like the way he describes things not like I found a totem
it's so strange he's not like is that a totem as if he can
see looks like a snake judging by the
teeth if that's a snake that is like a humongous skull are
we not concerned actually I think we should start reporting
on the size of the giant snakes that are in this forest.
Let's say it was my birthday.
Sayo!
Happy birthday!
Happy belated birthday!
Oh, well, gosh.
It's so hard to see.
There's another one.
Well, you always were a kidder, meinto.
I am kidding now.
I am messing around.
Why'd the audio stop?
Wait.
Is this a saloop?
Wait, where are we?
Oh, it is.
Okay.
Let's go this way Maybe it's illusion of choice.
They all loop around Hopefully maybe
Something leads to They're siphoning our our electricity?
It's a full-on ritual site there's bones candles everything
I can't fucking believe it man
That's not what the subtitle said.
And some of these candles are lit.
You think someone's been there recently?
Maybe.
Wait, hold on.
I want to go around the other way.
The way that I...
Let's see.
Was there here?
Why sometimes... I can't tell how... I can't determine how
tall we are.
Sometimes we look huge and sometimes tiny.
It might just circle around, you know.
Oh.
Oh, it does, it does.
Then there's this way, and then there's the other way.
Oh, they're listening to the radio!
Do you believe the truth?
Through squirrels, you are born.
Do you believe the truth through squirrels, you are born?
Do you believe the truth?
Truth.
Through squirrels, we are reborn.
You guys, I have this.
What goes around comes around.
Oh, man.
The cult's kind of cringe.
What the hell is this for?
Hi, Bu-chan.
Hi.
What do you guys do you like?
You missed one!
I wouldn't touch this.
The serpent whispers beneath the noise.
Only those who listen will move forward.
And then this thing again.
The serpent whispers beneath the noise.
Only those who listen will move forward.
Does it lose your mind?
I found something in the cave.
He's really not taking this seriously.
The whisper's part, maybe.
There's static in here.
Almost like the signal's off somehow.
Let me know if you figure out what that means.
I'm looking into the Urobore of Sting.
Hmm.
Maybe he's part of it, right?
Maybe that's why he sent me in here.
The, uh, low-eat mushrooms are very cool, though.
I like those.
Um...
Oh, look, maybe they used it for the eye.
That's cool.
You figure out anything about the symbol yet?
Not really.
I got an idea.
The radio spicked up some weird shit.
Oh, that's what I'm doing, yeah.
Hmm.
Only those who listen will move forward.
Yeah.
This is the Ashford Creek National Park emergency station
providing...
What is they listening to?
Oh, I can't see it.
Oh, this is what they're listening to.
We turn around and it's a bunch of guys in robes like...
I didn't.
Doing like Charlie Brown dance.
You have to wonder what some of these stations are.
Oh, I found it.
Oh.
I listened?
Is there more?
I thought the door might open.
Maybe it does now.
Huh.
Does this mean anything to you?
Hmm.
Let's keep going down, I guess.
Okay.
What is that?
I think that somebody is I think that's a radio.
I think that's a walkie-talkie.
The music suddenly sounds so silent, Hill.
Is it just me?
Oh.
Oh, no, it's not.
It's a compass.
Got something by a water pool here.
Compass.
Looks classic.
It's...
Wait, hold on.
The needle's spinning.
That's not normal, right?
No.
No way.
It's like...
Got your camera.
Something's caught in a field or something.
Like something's messing with it.
right near the water on a rock I'm starting to get worried
and that's what the feds found out there keep it that kind
of reaction might not be random yeah it's in good shape too
check if there's a name or marking oh I will do that I'll
check right now where's my compass I'll check if I'll check
it right now can I look at it wait check the compass?
Never mind.
Oh.
Dang it.
I'm confused why I did the ritual, like that radio thing.
It didn't do anything, so I'm kind of like, okay.
Oh.
Oh!
Thank you so much!
Did you pick it up?
I did.
It was in my inventory.
Oh.
Led by the will of the Ouroboros, Overseer...
Victor, though!
Oh my god.
He's got them ghost sleeves.
Why everything be whispering, though?
I found something here.
Some kind of inscription.
Maybe we should also mention, though...
Led by the will of the Ouroboros.
And a name.
Overseer, Victor Thorn.
Victor Thorn?
Yeah.
Ring any bells?
Not that I know of.
Looks like he wasn't just some believer.
He was the one running it.
Well, at least we've got a name now.
We had a name.
We just didn't know what it was for.
Maybe I'd do my thing here, too.
Okay.
Yeah, we're not going to talk about the entire monument
built dedicated to him.
Fine.
sure not important not important at all don't worry about it
oh open it's on our side no why why can't we just glossing
over at some of the insignificant details is
this gonna open did I miss something I did your I did your
maybe we have to turn this on and also my radio the spoils
the spoils oh here we go I can't
hear it
The serpent leads us to truth through the spoils.
Echoed.
Oh.
Serpent.
We need us.
We need to seek truth.
We need to wait.
Remember us.
Beeched.
No.
What do you mean, no?
Are you the cultists?
Is this your sight?
think they are but confirm not possible we are many many
echo one zero echo beach come higher dimension access
possible access possible can i go there higher dimension how
do i get there do i want to go silly approach better they
call me silly turn back it is out there it is Waiting.
What's waiting?
Beach.
Echo.
Konets?
What?
I don't think cultists would ever affirm being a cultist.
I don't think so either.
Robert, I just used the radio down here.
Some kind of voice came through.
It was distorted.
Fractured.
What did it say?
I mentioned Echo Beach?
Yeah, because I kept talking about Echo Beach.
I said things.
You mentioned like a beach.
It called an echo beach This happened before yeah this
happened before at the Ranger cabin.
I'm not crazy.
All right, let's try to stay grounded here This isn't just
random static.
It talked to me.
Yeah Okay, let me know immediately if that voice shows up
again and don't touch anything else that talks back Oh, are
we going out of the cave now?
maybe
jump jump okay um whatever something's waiting for me what
is this I found something looks like a makeshift lift oh
we're going down again ropes pulleys looks like amateur work
but sturdy this looks like amateur work this looks pretty
impressive to me okay oh oh Not the cultist graffiti.
That doesn't look makeshift at all.
Yeah, this doesn't look amateur.
This looks extremely well put together.
We're such a hater.
Oh!
Fresh air!
Wait, something's waiting for me.
What did they say?
I'm scared.
Wait.
Oh, we're back here again.
The compass.
Uh, I'm trying to run.
The Symbol's here again.
What does that mean?
Um, can I run?
Can I leave?
Can I go?
Oh, shoot.
Uh, it won't let me leave.
Can't put the axe up.
What is happening?
Um.
Ah!
Oh, he's dropping.
Oh my god, he's wanting to kiss me.
He wants to kiss me.
Leave me alone!
Oh god, he's huge!
Oh, it's all dark in hand.
I wonder if that's supposed to happen or okay all right
let's try something else
I think maybe hello friend um Rob help me the symbol is here
again what does that mean Rob Rob
who can blame him though oh holy shit just happened defeat
your first enemy first hey you hear me i'd appreciate your
help here what i've seen is just up hey you gotta be kidding
me don't tell me the battery's dead god damn it with these
things where do i charge this now charge your walkie-talkie
or batteries what's a metal door like this doing in the
middle of the woods so we have cultists and the government
and wendigos and everything, everything that we could ever
imagine going on in here is happening.
Allegedly.
Cut with some bolt cutters.
Um.
Mm-hmm.
Mm.
Bolt cutters, you say.
The things that I've definitely been uh...
Definitely been given Everyone wants a piece of Minky.
It's true.
Game?
I'm in need of some gamer paint.
Alright, maybe amongst the bushes.
No?
Aliens, Cultist, Monsters?
This game is an X-Files episode.
For real though.
Up over the ridge.
Wait, what do you mean?
Ah!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you so much.
Wait, I didn't get any bolt cutters.
Was I supposed to somewhere?
Huh.
Was I supposed to get bolt cutters somewhere?
Maybe, maybe back by the weird tent?
Maybe?
I don't think they would soft lock this hard, right?
Uh.
Maybe by the...
This one.
Is that?
No.
Uh.
Like, I feel like they'd put them over here, no?
The music floor.
Oh, I found them!
I found them!
Yeah!
Okay, we're safe.
I had a feeling it would be something like that, right?
Okay, cool.
I'm actually... I'm running, but it feels like I'm walking.
I am, I am, you guys can't tell, but I'm definitely in a
hurry.
Okay.
Uh.
Friend?
Oh, the battery's dead.
That's right.
Oh, okay.
Uh.
Oh.
I don't want to be fighting guys anymore now.
Pretty music.
Why does it feel like Minecraft?
Music disappears?
Are we gonna have to fight somebody?
Wait, I have wooden planks.
I do, I do.
Where am I at?
We're at!
Granite Ridge!
We made it to someplace.
Hold shift, V-Tuber.
Okay, I'm holding shift.
We're doing it, we're doing it!
Okay, hold on.
What was our, oh.
Now we're on the map!
But there was another way, hold on.
There was a second pathway, I wanna go check that out too.
Okay, let's see.
Good soundtrack in this game.
An actual deer!
This is the way I was gonna go.
You don't think it's gonna transform into an evil thing, do
you?
Hi!
He's got such a big OPN eyes!
What's that over there?
Something shiny there, too.
Oh, he's running?
Oh, what is this over here?
Bye.
What a lovely night.
We're at
the camp.
Welcome.
Welcome to Blackwood Camp.
I'm your hostess with the mostest.
Uh, ready to have a bear.
good time.
You're one creepy bear, aren't you?
Stare at the camp bear for an awkwardly long time.
Oh, I got an achievement for looking at him.
Oh, reach Blackwood Camp.
Ashwood Creek's annual harvest fest.
Hoor, hoor, hoor.
Hmm.
Okay.
Just supplies.
and stuff can I not charge my my walkie-talkie here can I
not do that wait take yoink yoink no okay ice cream oh this
gotta be a prank oh after all that we've seen tonight you're
gonna believe that the hand that a bone is a prank I I don't
believe it.
I don't believe this.
Where is everyone?
Are we with like an alternate dimension or something?
How is the... I think we are.
How is the flag staying like this?
He is a very smart man.
Truly.
Right, that was a good one, wasn't it?
Got some energizing.
Kinda... freaky.
Guys, they're very courageous or very stupid.
Oh, I wonder where the keys could be.
I wonder.
I'm a cop.
No!
Let me in.
They're like, you're a fake cop.
I keep seeing this thing and I keep thinking it's a person.
A pumpkin patch!
Oh, yeah.
Oh, we made it in, we made it in.
Let's go.
They roasted marshmallows and sang songs before going to
sleep.
This marshmallow has been out here for four days, by the
way.
Oh, yeah.
Look at them carcinogens, baby.
Catch on fire.
I just looked at it and then put it in my pocket.
It's like sticky and disgusting in my bag.
Oh yeah My marshmallow stick
Friends made in Ashwood Friends for life Okay but It's just
a lie I don't think I've Luke's tent Luke's tent I haven't
talked with or thought of anybody Anybody From camp Oh, they
give us another shot for matches.
There you go, buddy.
Aw, returned Elliot's compass.
How did that get here?
Um, hello?
I think I have to use the thing on it again, right?
Oh, what was that?
Someone did this to Elliot.
they targeted him all
right everyone time to get settled we've got a big day ahead
of us tomorrow so no wandering off okay except you Elliot
you're allowed to wander off I guess just thinking you ever
feel like something's waiting for you like there's this
thing out there watching sure the trees the stars it's a
little scary at first but that's the woods for you it's just
nature i don't know i used to think i'd be the kind of
person who finds things solve stuff you know like indy he
does like indy to you kid everyone gets that way sometimes
you're my people we've got a good crew here you've got the
ranger looking out for you too the range what about harvey
huh i've seen you talking to him yeah he's been around a lot
talks like he knows things that's just harvey for you always
mysterious all right now off to bed boys is
it always the same frequency
it always seems to be that one like the one over here
Doom came out last year.
Wait, that's so fun.
Is it just going to keep whispering at me?
Whose tent is this?
We don't care.
The twins.
Uh.
Okay.
Locked.
Nothing else, alright.
He wants to find things like Indy does.
Oh, it's that popcorn, yeah!
Oh, it's his channel again.
And that brings me to the next part of the show.
The strange show.
Weird stuff people believe.
And tonight we're talking about the best conspiracies.
Now, I know some of y'all out there are nodding along like
you know exactly what I'm talking about.
stuff people believe ashwood creek sits on top of a magnetic
anomaly you know one of those weird places where compasses
spin out of control and radios get all messed up yeah we
have to recharge my radio until you realize well you can't
find your own way home i don't say ghosts others say it's
something much more ominous they talk about shadows in the
woods or even light dancing in the sky late at night aliens
how many times do i have to say it i'm saying it with my
full Yes.
But in all seriousness, if there was something out there,
some hidden power buried beneath the hills.
Well, we wouldn't know, would we?
We just keep going about our lives, thinking everything's
fine until one day something does happen.
Oh.
Well, folks, that's all the time we've got.
Remember, as much as we like to poke fun at the stranger,
Strange and unusual, the real world can be just as
unsettling.
Keep your eyes and ears open, especially with Little Elliot
still missing.
Oh my goodness.
Every little detail helps.
Hmm.
They be eating good.
Reesies.
Reesies for breakfast?
No, Reesies cereal.
Who the heck?
Guys, they don't tell you this, but this is actually Apple.
This is how...
This is...
Oh, sorry.
I'm sorry.
That's actually Microsoft.
That's how...
That's how the first computer was built.
Can I charge my...
My...
My walkie-talkie, please.
Take it, take it, take it!
Dang it.
It won't let me take any more of the... Oh, what's this?
Taki Charger is available for anyone part in the search for
Elliot Lair.
Cabin number three.
For more information, find Fred Kirkley Groundskeeper.
Oh, logbook.
Oh, whoops.
Group arrived late.
Missing one permission form.
Ranger approved verbal check-in staying two nights.
September 1st.
Camp temporarily closed due to active investigation.
So was the permission form that was missing?
Was that Elliot?
Yeah.
John Michael yeah you believe it you should you should Jake
unknown group no permit no paperwork warned group leader not
to return without proper authorization quote-unquote Jake
Troy and Melissa backpacking from Clearwater stepped stopped
here overnight something wrong with the air left early color
so not just like kids stay here like regular people stay
here too oh yeah food's half eaten they must have left in a
hurry this is a whole plate full oh no i couldn't finish my
potato and cheese let's meet for dinner i've been in the
camp so many times but this time something ain't right don't
tell the others yet luke what does that mean Something ain't
right about this place.
Something ain't right.
Food's half eaten.
They must have left in a hurry.
We got some maybe baked beans.
Girl dinner.
What is that?
What the hell was that sound?
Oh, please be a raccoon.
Please be a raccoon.
A raccoon.
that ate the food.
Please.
Snuffy.
Yeah, Snuffy.
What the hell?
Some kind of electrical problem?
Oh my god.
It's an actual horror game.
I also didn't shut that door.
But these doors don't need electricity to open, right?
I want to go into the luxurious guest room, please.
The guest room class.
Imagine.
Oh, wow.
I can't wait to stay here.
Oh, we got a guest room.
Sorry, you did not get guest room luxury.
This is, you get guest room classic.
I didn't shut that door.
Um, was there a I saw something before and now I don't
remember was it in oh gosh I'm scared guys I'm scared okay
oh gosh he scared me too yeah you get the lame guest room
generator outside oh it's dark this light's still on was it
in here the office Oh, but the...
Oh, no.
Wait, where did I see it?
Am I crazy?
Where's cabin number three?
I have no idea.
Uh.
My objective was to investigate the power outage, but,
like...
Where?
By the deer figure.
Was it?
No.
Oh, yes, thank you.
Oh.
Hello.
What do you want from me?
Oh, now we can take some pliers.
Do I need this for the...
Uh.
Hello.
Hello?
I'm confused.
Thank you.
Guys, I'm confused.
There was nothing in here.
Still full.
Didn't stick around.
for a refill yep
uh was there something in here that I missed no
I'm not sure behind the cabin I guess so I thought that
there would maybe be like a thing that says like you know
wait they didn't even they dropped their popcorn still
smells like burnt sugar yum butter
you'd think that there would be some sort of like hey this
is the place that you go to fix the power when it goes out
still on well we'll just look around I guess I won't worry
about it for now yeah I guess it may be care kettle corn or
caramel popcorn or something more pliers can never have too
many I suppose I'm gonna go out into the lake and recreate
ace attorney oh it's that wait whose house is that great
my shoes are soaking wet oh my god this guy is the biggest
complainer ever you're such a complainer though oh wait
maybe that here we go here we go can I get up there.
Oh, hill too big.
I don't know how to use my arms and my legs.
Wasn't I injured?
What happened with that?
Wasn't I supposed to have some sort of leg injury?
I fell 30 feet.
Totally okay though.
Don't worry guys.
Elliot search operation.
A search party base of operations.
Okay.
Creepy.
We walked it off truly okay gosh I really wish I could go
faster in this game I am so slow well here we go here we go
we found it what the hell the cables cut oh wow a clean cut
You bet I am.
Get out of here, you slimy little thief.
I'm a police investigator.
Where are your legs?
Sir.
I know you work out here in the woods, but you don't have to
take the twig seriously.
I'm Officer Collins.
You don't have to be a twig, mister.
Hold on.
You're a cop?
I'm a cop.
Sorry about that, mister.
Oh, you just believe me.
Fred I work oh the groundskeeper receptionist groundkeeper
you name it was asleep in the back when the power went out
thought I'd check what was going on someone cut the someone
cut your wire hey Fred someone's cut your wire you've had a
lot of thieves around here oh yes thieves hooligans that's
why I came here you're not even armed are you nah most
scumbags just did you hear me try to does the rest thank you
for patching actually I'm not a thief are you looking for
the boy too like the fellows in the search I can't move by
the way where are they I'm looking for them where are they
they were just here I helped serve dinner even but something
spooked them they cleared out in a hurry what spooked them
beats me just woke up powers out and now you're here look
it's cold out I'll make us some tea you look like you've had
a rough night my bone is literally what if my leg bone is
sticking out of my leg look at this guy my God how can you
walk Fred wait oh there you go yay Jack Skellington I guess
we'll talk to him, right?
Patch the generator cable.
That's what I did.
Just wait for the tea.
What else are we going to do, huh?
Ask him a question.
Here's to tea.
Hope you don't mind it strong.
Oh my god, Fred.
Spill it, girl.
What is...
I love me.
tea where is it oh thank you so what brings you out here
this late something to do with the boy huh something like
that what about you why are you still here someone's got to
keep the lights on hey plus this place doesn't run itself
especially with the search party coming and going they need
a fellow down here they can count on can i ask you a couple
of questions i'm always so thirsty you guys I just down my
drinks but call me Fred and ask whatever um Elliot there was
a scout camping trip three days ago where the boy went
missing oh yes terrible do you know anything about it well
the camp's been around forever kids have been pitching tents
and learning how to tie knots out there since before I even
moved here the kids the kids be pitching tents out there are
what about about him oh sure the rangers and the scouts
cross paths all the time makes sense right rangers keep an
eye on the park and the scouts are always out hiking camping
poking around harvey was friendly enough with them what does
that mean well you know basic stuff trail safety teaching
the kids to identify poison oak from regular shrubs that
kind of sorry wasn't close to them as luke was but I do
remember seeing him and Elliot talking a few times but
Elliot seemed to like him almost look up to him what do they
talk about yeah about what I couldn't say for sure just
caught a couple of conversations between them here and there
okay might have been nothing Harvey's the kind of guy who
keeps himself to himself but isn't that kind of odd officer
what Elliot disappears and then not long after Harvey's gone
too you tell me if that's a coincidence oh yeah what about
the search party you said they were just here he's
incriminating anything unusual well they've been in and out
a lot mostly at night seems stressed i don't blame them
considering the kids still missing but luke the scout leader
he has not been acting right i'll tell you kept pacing
outside muttering i saw him exchange a few words with harvey
felt off entirely you think they're in it together did he
say anything to you no not to me then the group left in a
hurry haven't seen them since you've been working here a
while haven't you must know the park pretty well oh yeah
coming on 30 years now but some folks say the park's got a
weird history you know small town lots of gossip little
proof what kind of gossip are we talking oh the usual.
People claim they've seen lights in the woods, heard voices.
There's even talk of that old cult from the 70s.
Oro, Oro something?
Crony?
Oh my god.
Yeah, that's it.
Creepy stuff.
But probably just stories to scare the kids.
Thanks for answering my questions, Fred.
Oh, absolutely.
Wasn't much, I'm afraid.
If you're heading back out there, be careful.
The woods can play tricks on you at night.
Thanks for the tea.
I'll keep that in mind.
for the tea.
Yes, it's the, uh, oh, thank you.
Search party's cabin key.
Oh, that must be cabin three, right?
All right.
What was it?
Did you make a funny noise?
All right.
Very good, very good.
got the tea girlfriend he gave us what is this horrible
noise coming from out here oh my gosh that a raccoon got in
here too tore everything apart oh logs face this is carter
negative on sighting in section wh fogs whispering hollows
right visibility shit keep everyone in pairs please i don't
want to the goddamn search party for the search okay speak
up we've got what looks like small footprints up above the
quarry oh could be him maybe he doubled back i'll check the
lower path alone just in case okay i know the protocol
carter i'll keep the line open no luck here anyone got
anything near the lake trash pan they're looking for some
food exactly wait did you hear that cut the chatter unless
it's relevant did you hear that I know you
don't trust the silence after your name E-T-H-A-M
What does that mean?
They were covering sector four tonight and they went to the
camp and then where Sector four is what no signal here
Oh There we go.
And that's our kid.
Don't trust the silence after your name.
Alright, let's charge my walkie.
How long do I have to wait actually?
I just realized.
Ooh.
This is pretty spooky, isn't it?
The way they speak in, like, pre-recorded lines is pretty
cool.
It's like, you know how...
Ghost hunters will try to get EVPs, electronic voice
phenomenas.
They'll, like, use, like, a spirit box, aka a radio, and try
and see if, like, a ghost will talk in the spirit box or
whatever.
And it's usually just, like, a thing cycling through a bunch
of radio stations.
Okay.
Is it good?
Battery dead?
Maybe I...
For some reason I thought it would be instantaneous.
So I was like, oh, we'll listen to the blogs after.
Or listen to it before.
Anything in here?
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh, the best hits for me!
Bon...
John Bovy!
New cover reveal.
Oh.
Oh yeah.
Uh.
What do I do?
How long must I wait?
I mean to spirit box merch when?
It'll be like...
Hey.
Food.
Cheese it.
Now.
Don't.
Extra crispy.
This is Ethan.
Robert, do you copy?
I repeat, this is Ethan.
Over.
He went to bed.
It's been too long.
Jesus.
You would darken me for hours.
I was ready to send a damn chopper.
You should have done that a long time ago.
Where are you now?
That was hours ago?
He grouped up with the search party?
No, they're gone.
They must have pursued a lead.
Shopping's Jesus into my spare box.
Uh, midnight.
Ten minutes later.
They good, yeah.
Yep.
I know how it sounds.
No, you don't.
Sounds like you're slipping again.
Slipping?
I'm not drinking.
Not on duty.
Not anymore.
Doesn't matter.
It's the same pattern, man.
You zone out, vanish.
You chase things that aren't there.
Then you're back hammered.
It's the same shit.
That was years ago.
You said you wouldn't bring it up.
Yeah, well maybe I shouldn't.
Oh, say it.
Don't be a coward.
Say it.
Then say it.
You think I lost it back then?
I don't know.
Back then, you barely remember it any time.
you were talking about voices and shit something like a
total lunatic and you didn't believe me just like now no I
didn't believe something happened but you are a wreck man
and I didn't want to add fuel to that fire what does that
mean well you know we have people missing feds out there you
knew what the feds were doing not all of it just enough but
now you know too wait what's going on
You lied.
So, you lied.
And you call yourself my friend.
Well, first of all, it's a government secret.
I wasn't even supposed to know.
And the fact that you're my friend is why I had to lie.
I was trying to protect you.
Your career would be over.
We wouldn't be talking now.
What now?
So, what now?
We are in the middle of it.
Tell me what you think.
something's missing
search party found something something spooked them i
wouldn't say exactly harvey's behind this but at the same
time it's still sus i don't know nothing adds up i can't see
the whole picture yeah something's missing i've got to keep
looking but fucking where
Rob What?
Stop fucking playing with me, Robert Shut the fuck up and
tell me if you see that too What?
I want to see what?
See what?
See what, Robert?
I go, no!
Oh, look who too?
What the fuck?
I see it.
So there's a huge fucking light beam in the sky, right?
It's not just me.
You see it from the station?
Right, you lit up the whole town.
It's just past the camp.
Looks like Misty Trail.
They mentioned this in the report, right?
The one in a tent.
Civilians mentioned a light.
Sight deemed unstable.
You believe me now?
Yeah.
I believe me now?
Yeah, you believe me now?
shit happening here what I don't even know anymore but there
is a light beam in the sky so it's safe to say you're not
imagining this one get to the light
can barely see hey man you want to see this it's crazy oh
hello where'd you go Fred Fred
He can't leave his hamster!
Oh my gosh, I've been obsessed recently with watching this
like, there's these hamsters on TikTok, not hamsters, sorry.
They're these flying squirrels on TikTok and they get on the
wheel and they go like, and then they'll fly, they'll like
fling each other off and then another one will get on and be
like, and then another one will get on and be like, and then
another one will get on and be like, and then it'll get
caught in its sphere and it'll go, and it'll fly off!
It's so crazy!
I think we lost him!
Fred!
Where are you?
But do they kiss?
They don't.
Not to my knowledge.
Fred?
Where the heck did he go?
Oh my gosh, my neighbor is like cooking.
And it smells so good.
And I'm like, I want to eat.
Wait, can we go with pumpkin patch?
Oh, how cute!
Oh my gosh, wait, place ripe pumpkins here.
Yikes!
Somebody bailed mid-carve.
Or they just, that's, no, that's the look, that's the look.
What's for dinner, I don't know yet.
I do not know.
Hope you have a good meal later.
Yeah, we'll get one right after this game.
Hehehehe.
Anybody having something good to eat?
Please report to me.
Knock on their door.
Yeah, can I please?
I'm so hungry.
You know what?
I'm done just sitting on my ass.
I don't know what the hell's going on, but this thing, it's
not natural.
So, what now?
No, it's just like a...
I'm getting whoever I can.
Then I'm coming to the work myself.
Are you sure?
No way.
We're gonna face whatever this is.
You're not doing it for us.
Rob!
Rob, please!
I was gonna, um... What was I gonna say?
uh uh it's like that thing in minecraft that the the beam
that you can use you can place down and you'll see it from
far far away guys no rush by the way obviously i'm like you
know this is as fast as i can run yeah the beacon it's a
beacon no please don't tell me this is a dead end no i went
the wrong No way!
No!
Hope you're having a good day streaming though.
You two!
Thank you so much for 29 months!
Corsian, thank you.
Nor.
How could this happen to me?
I think we, I guess we crossed the bridge then.
Oh my gosh, it's so loud.
Goodness.
You'd think that would be, like, audible from the cabins
down there.
Alright, children, it's time to sleep.
Everyone have a great, peaceful night in the middle of the
woods in this camp.
Everybody get some restful, restful Z's tonight.
That looks like we're supposed to escape from that way or
something.
Hello?
There we go.
Whoa.
Excuse me.
Chota mate a minute.
Uh.
What's this over here?
Could this be the entrance to a cave full of cult
activities?
Unlock it?
Oh.
We're on a cave entrance here.
Metal gate.
It's locked.
Let's be at a cave at the waterfall.
Been locked for ages.
I see.
What happened?
What happened in there?
Yeah, why?
Not sure, actually.
I think it's just generally unsafe.
You know how the caves are around here, right?
And trust me, after today, I know.
Ho ho ho.
I don't know.
Not really.
Oh, there we go.
Climb.
These ledges are, like, we, they, we come up, these ledges
come up to my chins.
Like they're so tall.
How are little children, how are little children climbing
over these?
How do they cross the river?
Naruhodo.
Wait.
I think we're close, guys.
Knock it over.
What is that?
Oh.
I can't...
Oh, now I can zoom.
What is that?
I found some kind of a thing here.
Uh...
A force?
It's some kind of a force.
It won't let me pass Huh, sir, this is a real emergency we
got a light beam in the sky.
Hello?
I'm trying to talk to you.
Yes, I know how that sounds.
Hello?
I'm the one in actual danger here The FVC will be here stat
Sir Fuck you on your way to the damn light?
I am this Things in the way.
Well, you gotta find a way to get past it.
Oh, thanks
Scout.
Find out soon.
It was Mouth.
It was Mouth?
Ugh!
It's just up ahead.
You're gonna love this.
Are you sure we're allowed?
No signs.
No gates.
Just stone in time.
Okay.
Just feels off.
Is that the point?
You'll see.
Places like this stick with you.
I just saw something I tuned into a frequency and there were
people it's people a boy and an older guy just like that in
front of me describe them one was older guy strong guy had a
strong build sounded like Luke Jenkins they were heading
somewhere I think it's Luke I think it's Luke not Harvey the
guy mentioned showing Elliot something cool Jesus yeah and
that wasn't a recording They were right here.
I could hear them.
Yeah.
You think you saw some kind of a memory or a different
dimension?
Yeah.
Different time.
And I saw what looked like Luke and Elliot.
Yeah.
Really?
Maybe you were right to suspect Luke.
Uh-huh.
He's been helping with the search.
He reported a mission.
Wait, what?
Oh, yeah.
This doesn't add up, right?
He's lying.
Everyone describes him as the kind of guy you'd meet.
Yeah.
When you're kind, it's easy to fool anyone.
Dun dun.
Oh, look.
Old man Jenkins.
It was him all along.
We're so close.
Wait, can we climb that?
No, we gotta go around maybe.
Hmm.
Old man Jenkins.
It's always old man Jenkins.
All right.
What the heck?
We're so close.
I'm surprised it doesn't make a noise like oh man we got
some cool activities up in here guys oh wow Robert I'm at
the light maybe we should be using our inside quiet voices
copy of course are we going okay excuse me no cult
activities allowed here oh the game just saved why would it
do that
oh what was that
I'm so small compared to
everybody hello oh my god it scared me hey mr.
Jenkins is that you I'm not Mr. Jenkins.
I'm not, but I'll help.
You've got to help me.
I think... I think it's going to happen again.
What?
What is...
Where are you?
I don't want to.
I think he's returning.
I...
Hurry.
You've got to help me before he plugs me back in.
Plugs you back in.
Hey!
Uh...
It was like bootleg Bruno Mars, but it was so catchy.
It was great.
Here we go.
Hey, quit it.
Quit it, you guys.
I'm playing your favorite song.
Interesting.
Thank you.
Is it going to make you guys bow too?
Okay.
And it's a blue.
It's a white light.
Uh-huh.
Alright.
This looks good.
No, no, no.
We got to do this.
We got to fix this.
We got to fix this, you guys.
Echo beach.
Do not die.
Oh, do not.
What is this?
Time.
Convergence.
Do not.
Oh, what happens if I touch it?
What happens if I do?
One.
C said.
Forget.
No one.
Return.
Whoa.
Close.
What is Echo Beach?
What's Echo Beach?
I should have asked about Elliot.
What are you trying to say?
Call.
Echo Beach.
Oh.
But I'm trying.
trap what what do you want from me the hell do you want from
me anchor vessel signal you tune reshape Ethan Ethan
indecisive it is Ethan close it blows it
Oh they're gone
No!
Ew!
I don't think I can find a signal until it starts coming at
me.
Oh, there we go.
Nope.
There we go.
Ethan, remember?
Ethan.
Is there a star coming?
They are coming.
Ethan, remember they are coming.
Where, where?
Ah!
Oh!
Oh, geez.
Okay.
okay oh they
kind of you guys all know that there's that game I wonder if
I'm supposed to keep going oh had that to the list I saw
Elliot in the light beam he screamed for help and he was
just gone you what um there's a series there's a game series
that looks like these guys i can't remember it right now
it's fine
anyway is it a horror game it's not horror per se but it's a
little creepy uh i see no hold on it's gonna bother me
hold on i got this it's like a puzzle game it's like a
puzzle game.
Yeah, I'll remember in the middle of the night.
So true.
I think it's an indie game.
I have one of them.
For some reason, my brain is like Stanley Parable, but
that's not it.
That's definitely not it.
Not it at all.
Um.
And there, oh.
Yeah, it is kind of like the beast room over the garden
wall.
Ah, they were in Outer Wilds.
No, no, no.
The Black Cube puzzle game.
Yes, but there's like, hold on, black cube puzzle game.
Yes, it's that one.
But, no, wait.
No?
No.
Wait, no.
Oh, what is it?
Yes, the Rusty Lake series!
That's it!
That's why it keeps like, my brain.
Rusty Lake series!
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
That's actually it.
there's like a thing and there's a guy in it that like looks
just like these things very creepy yeah thank you I knew
yeah cube escape that's why I thought it was black cube
right or there was like it has some something to do with a
cube in it anyway what were we saying um something and the
radio I talked to that voice again yeah but it was more like
a presence that's when the light beam exploded jesus christ
yeah all right i managed to raise a few guys from the county
before the phone went out i'm switching to handheld and i'm
leaving now okay return to blackwood camp all right don't
have to ask me twice can i go this way nice well surely
we're wait where are we actually wait where are we surely
we're not in danger now right because am I going the right
way I don't remember any of this I'm not on the map wait oh
yes I am oh I'm so far I didn't even realize how far it was
that's okay um we should be fine for now right where do all
the cult guys go this is This is the quarry?
I'm heading down into some kind of old quarry.
Trying to find my way back.
Copy that.
I'm getting in the car.
Signal might get spotty.
Only call in if it's urgent, all right?
You got it.
Do I have to go in?
Not exactly what I'd call a safe place.
Right.
Something's going on over here.
Can I take that?
I think for self-defense.
Sorry to bother.
Not to bother at all.
Shinobod had a really bad...
They were considering quitting but bills.
No, no, Cerberus.
I'm so sorry.
Get some rest.
Get something yummy to eat.
For sure, for sure.
See you later.
Not to bother at all.
How dare you say.
Whoa, quarry.
We've been talking about quarries a lot recently, I feel
like.
Is there stuff in here?
Should I just leave?
Like, it feels like I can explore in here a little bit more
or something.
Actually, I don't know if I can...
No.
Ha!
Ooh.
Hippipipipipipip.
Hippipip.
Wait!
This is the place.
Is this the one that I...
Yes!
We're here!
Hippie!
What's that sound?
Fred!
Fred.
Fred?
Find out where the blood leads.
Um...
Emergency!
Don't call unless it's an emergency.
Oh, well, funny thing about that is it is one.
I guess, was this open before?
It must have been.
Wait, no, maybe not.
Here we go.
Oh, no.
me.
Don't push me.
Are we stupid?
Why are we not telling anybody?
Why are we not calling anyone?
That's a handprint!
Oh my god.
Why are we not calling it?
Me one.
Does it go up there?
What's in here?
What's this?
I got a metal bracket and a metal bracket.
And some support beams.
Okay, interesting.
They don't go this way, do they?
I think that's Harvey!
I think we found Harvey.
Explorers.
He has this photo.
Wait, what was it?
I know you're out there.
Wound looks weird.
Sloppy job.
Sloppy Joe.
Sorry, I'm hungry.
Wound looks weird.
Take that.
Sloppy job.
Leg's broken.
Oh my god.
Good night.
Uh, hi.
Uh...
Got a dead body here.
It's Harvey.
No.
Wait, didn't I take the key?
There's a photo in his hand.
It's David and him.
Can't this thing go any faster.
Is it night?
Are you sure it's him?
It's him.
God damn it.
Give me the same details.
Blood everywhere.
Yeah, blood everywhere.
hip and neck looks like some real sloppy cuts with a sharp
object he's on his back head turned to the side one arms out
reaching for the photo he knew something he responded to
something whatever it was it got him killed that's it our
only lead on Elia's gone well what about Luke Jenkins what
about Luke Jenkins the search parties off the grid who knows
what happened to them Ethan yeah they could have ended up
like Harvey Search area for clues.
Go up, they say.
I'm listening to the birds and the nature.
Or stranger things music.
Sometimes when I get to these buildings, it makes me go
really slow.
Can I get a helicopter out of here, please?
that I'm gonna die.
Somebody help me please.
He's still...
He's still out there.
I saw him last winter.
Some place.
Oh, same place.
I know it was him.
What the hell?
Who is this?
What the... Is that someone's voice?
Wait, hold on.
it's been 10 years i hear you i swear i hear you sometimes
swamp area is nothing new shoes washed up again checked west
ridge again dead silence those shoes that washed up tower
radio is picking up static loops short bursts midnight to
115 might not be interference hearing patterns wait okay
hold on i can't i can't work under these conditions can you
hear me This is Blackwood camp ranger tower.
Come in Hello radio check radio check
I think the signal is too weak for this.
I'm in the ranger tower Oh my god, I can't hear you.
Sorry.
It's so loud There's stuff inside the radio base just turned
on I'm getting something I'm getting he sounds like
Someone's talking to me sounds like someone's trying to talk
to me
Again, we make out what they're saying.
Ah.
Who's this is this?
Harvey!
Oh, there we go.
I fixed it.
Make shift.
Look at me.
Oh, it didn't do much.
Oh.
A vububub-vub.
Is there another one?
This should only be the one, no?
Why is the person on the radio playing the macarinas really
aggressively?
Ahub-vub-vub-vub-vub.
Harvey's left his badge here.
Huh.
Hello?
A reflector?
Am I missing something else on it?
Maybe there's something else that I need to attach to it
that...
Oh yeah, the signal booster!
I don't have, okay.
I wanted to read the stinking...
I wanted to read this.
Oh, test four.
Boost...
Is he searching for his brother?
because it said like he lost his brother too no faint signal
reversed audio sound like music or speech can't put it to
tune it back in test five splice line through copper wiring
and boosted from ground box got nothing i swear i picked up
his voice just now he was screaming for help he kept
repeating it over and over frequency was precisely 122.3 a.m
need to find a way to replicate saw a light again bridge
above gorge too steady for lantern too slow for flare new
New booster arrives tomorrow.
Gonna ring it straight to tower.
Need power and height.
He'll answer again.
I could feel it in the air.
Something's shifted tonight.
Hang tight, Dave.
I'm not done yet.
Was that his brother's name, Dave?
Okay, you said the booster was coming in the mail tonight?
Is there an Amazon box down here?
I remember Barry asking...
Barry asking if you were going to cover a Monogatari song.
Would you consider covering...
Someone was opening Orange Mint with Kiara.
That would be...
Actually, I did cover a song with Kiara.
I don't...
What was it called?
Kiara picked a song, so...
Why can't...
There we go.
Oh my goodness.
But Orange Mint would be fine.
Oh yeah!
Oh sorry, we can report the book, can't we?
My bad.
I forgot because everything's so loud up there.
got a notebook pretty detailed someone was experimenting
with radio tech signal theory frequencies antenna setups all
handwritten Jesus was it a Harvey looks like it he was
trying to reach someone his brother ten years back dozens of
pages trial and error there's mention of the light you see
that hmm
Is it not in here?
In here?
It doesn't...
It...
Wait, is it in here?
It must be right.
Oh, he must have been on his way!
To get the signal boost!
Oh, to put it up!
Yeah.
Found a delivery box next to the body.
There's...
thing inside a thing a thing i'm not a nerd i'm not like a
tech nerd okay looks like some what am i some geek okay i
guess we didn't really need to report that because we knew
what it's for we know what it's for i know game saved
do you copy hey do you copy this is officer collins ashwood
creek pd Uh,
what kind of trouble?
Uh, where are you?
What's your location?
I don't know.
And...
Listen, everything's going to be okay.
There's more officers on the way.
Are you alone?
What happened?
Yeah, what happened?
Can you tell me what happened?
I, uh, Mr. Friends.
Can you speak up?
I was just messing around.
Cabin lit the pick.
Then Lisa and Tyler ran off towards the boat house.
Oh, I wonder if it was those kids.
Stop blaming Maracas.
remember water a lot of it and a light can you tell me your
name david david have you been injured listen i unless it is
the brother i promise mr you're not in trouble you won't be
in trouble don't worry we just need to get you to safety
that's all listen everything's going to be okay there's more
officers on the way you
said that so you said david nice to Oh, is he repeating?
Did he call the cops on us?
Are you here to arrest me?
I swear we just wanted to camp.
Fuck.
Harvey?
You mean Harvey?
The park ranger?
No.
My brother Harvey?
He's gonna be so pissed.
Hello?
Can anyone hear me?
I need help.
David
Waters, Lisa Cowell, Tyler, Dean Wells.
Three local teenagers have failed to return home from a
weekend.
outing in Ashwood Creek National Park.
Last known location was a picnic site near Granite Trail,
believed to have been visited on the evening of July 14th.
And...
Oh, the shoe!
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm turning it back down just so we all don't get our
ears blasted just in case.
It says Dave on it!
Oh my god.
Whoa.
search that area for clues okay I don't know much well what
do you mean what do you mean I don't want this bouncing
around this edge man Rob what what are you I've covered for
you again today oh no I just heard David on the radio Robert
listen something just happened I I made Contact with what
sounded like Harvey's brother.
David waters Oh, the blood is still there The body's still
there No, no, it's Already happened I'll talk when you're
back Don't fuck this up again Whoa
Whoa Whoa, whoa, whoa!
A weird old symbol.
Ah, yeah, that's my channel.
Sometimes it's hard to tell if I'm getting it like, you
know, the strongest signal or not.
Maybe this one?
Same goddamn stretch of trees.
And nothing.
Harvey.
Every night.
What the hell?
What?
No way.
What the hell are you doing this late, Jenkins?
Jenkins!
What are you thinking?
Oh, no.
You know the caves are sealed off.
There's no markers.
Nothing.
What the hell are you doing, Luke?
Oh, God.
Search for Elliot and Skell Cave.
Rob?
Yeah.
Are you real?
Are you...
Really?
Robert?
What is this test?
Yeah, I'm fucking real.
I just heard a voice.
It was David.
David Waters.
What?
He spoke to me like he was still out there.
Like it was yesterday.
And then I heard you.
Not the you now.
You... from years ago.
This place is... Time is broken, yeah.
Something's wrong with your time, Rob.
Ethan.
I don't expect you to believe that.
No.
I believe you oh I had another one of those time distortions
it was Harvey he was watching them Elliot and Luke they
entered the caves that night he led Elliot through the caves
yeah and now Harvey dead and Elliot might still be down
there I'm going down to the caves to the caves I don't need
you no time there's no time to spare I'm doing it the right
thing for once oh my Oh my god, are we gonna do
self-sacrifice?
Wait, how do we get in though?
I won't, not yet.
Oh, did I get a key to go in?
It wasn't it locked?
It was over this way, I think.
I think, no, wait, over this way.
Let's, wait, am I crazy?
Wait.
Ah, I'm crazy.
Oh, weird.
Oh, we did get a key from his body.
That's right, that's right, that's right.
Thank you.
I don't even know how he can get here, even.
If, like, time is all screwy at the moment.
Oh, gotta go down this way.
Going down proper.
Hoo, hoo, hoo.
Alright.
I feel we're so close, you guys.
We're so close.
Stinking Luke and his stinking Colt.
I'm messing up time and Auroboros.
All right, let me in.
Let me in.
Okay, back in the mines.
The caves.
Silly cult?
Uh-oh.
Looks like there's going to be bad reception down here.
I got to do this on my own now.
Okay.
Oh Back in the 40s they used to lower miners down this shaft
here.
See these rusted bolts?
They're still wedged in the wall.
That's insane Why didn't they just build stairs?
Stairs wouldn't have felt as heroic, I guess.
Hey, Luke hold up a sec.
Come on.
You'll miss the good part There's a chamber up ahead Elliot
sounds so well will hear your blood moving Elliot Elliot hey
this isn't funny hello shit where'd you go where'd you Luke
what the hell are you doing here Elliot's gone we were just
looking around and then where did he go he went deep down
this passage I think damn it stay behind me
what the heck open mine shaft no is Elliot stupid I'm sorry
let me go through the area that is totally roped off and
nobody's allowed in are we dumb is he dumb okay I'd like to
look at the area that he was going to show us that was
really neat whispering hollow scale case part of Whispering
Hollow's system is known for its narrow passages, striking
rock formations, and cool underground stream.
Stay on designated paths, broke the first freaking rule.
This kid.
This freaking kid!
When will you learn?
Some visitors have reported unusual audio phenomena in the
area.
These occurrences are believed to be caused by the cave's
unique acoustics and dense granite walls.
There's little bats in here.
Okay.
Freaking bats.
Hmm.
There happens to have consequences.
He was brainwashed by the Ouroboros they planted under the
EP bag.
You're right.
He was just like, ooh, this is where they called to me.
Kid is nimble.
You can go through such planks.
Elliot!
But!
I'm an old man.
I have to knock everything down.
I can't.
You know.
It just sounds like someone's screaming.
Not my channel.
Lights are on, huh?
Not my jam.
Lazy Lumen.
Thank you so much for turning back!
29 boots!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
You're not spooked?
Me neither.
We're fine, maybe.
What's all the rumbling for, though?
Um, cult!
Can you stop doing the weird weird things?
Another statue?
How many of these did you make?
How did they get them?
Come down here!
She walks between light and shadow.
Return is promised.
I affirm.
Oh, heck yeah.
No!
I steal your sacrifices.
Don't do that, by the way, for, like, my stuff, because...
Because I'll be so sad.
Spike Nate, thanks for the quarter.
Thank you very much.
I guess this is for when we are trying to escape and
ultimately maybe running away from the cult and we have to
run back.
Maybe.
There's something moving over there?
Oh, I think it's one of those...
things that block our paths.
I thought it was a person at first.
I was like, no, please no sneaking game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't, yeah, I can't fall down there.
Listen closely, friends.
Some of you still do not understand why we chose this place.
This rock under us, solid granite, rich in quartz, Hi guys!
I'm the...
I'm the cult leader!
They carry vibrations.
Don't I sound like a...
Like a very...
Menacing force?
It's an anomaly of sort.
It makes this place unstable.
You guys are so bald.
But powerful.
And that's why we're here.
Don't look at me!
We won't be praying to gods.
We're going to tune ourselves to something bigger we're
gonna tune ourselves to something bigger the oroboros
resonator is built to do just that is it crude oh yes
friends a little these voice actors are killing me it has
worked oh no the subs are out timed but also a vessel strong
enough to carry the charge when the door opens for us time
isn't a line friends time isn't a line friends
time isn't aligned friends can i do that one one more time
hold on time isn't aligned friends
sorry i felt like the energy on that take was just not so
good and yeah let me try time isn't aligned friends
uh so i'm really enjoying this game though so don't i'm just
i'm just picking a little fun It's great.
Jacob, welcome back.
Thank you.
I'm just poking a little fun.
Another one.
And also their own antenna.
What is this?
What the hell is this?
Looks fucked up.
Oh my god.
They have a dentist simulator.
Time isn't a line.
That's why he said it twice.
It's actually what they did is a You know It's meant to be
like you know we we recurred like we had the past it
happened again It repeated itself.
That's what happened here
The serpent eats itself not out of hunger, but out of
knowing Friends we've spent decades tuning into frequencies
that stretch beyond just flesh We thought the symbol of
Ouroboros was simply a repetition.
Oh my gosh but it is resonance it is with resonance that we
can got the villain from detective conan these coils one
comes on each pylon they must align with the spine of the
resonator that's when the signal stabilizes rg rgb this
vessel it's not a sacrifice not death but transformation you
hold great power my friend when all aligns we will open the
way time will speak you see everything has a natural
frequency even time itself the resonator will carry our
signal not through air not space but through they're doing
this to me tomorrow I believe it was now friends take out
your devices let us listen oh my god they suck at this oh me
too should I I can feel it friends we're making contact here
Rejecting from Minecraft villagers.
No!
Yoink.
R.G.B.
Right.
That's one of the three.
Oh, they actually...
They write which one.
Okay, cool.
Wait, what?
That made a sound.
Sound like something opened up.
What the...
Wow.
Yold.
Um...
Schematics.
Okay!
They turned him into a coil!
I mean, that's what snakes do, no?
They coil.
Oh!
There's this way.
Okay, hold on.
Let's go up this way first.
Okay, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Sorry, it's such a good tune.
him again I swear he was just here Elliot do they see the
colds down here look it's not a crime to want to cheer up a
kid how could I have known he would just wander off there's
something up with the caves down here no kidding that lift
didn't look like it was left here by the miners how did that
even get here hey hard you with me I swear I what was that
you heard something no I thought I saw
oh this is not good what the hell is this place what the
it's the light listen we've got to go back and call the
police it's somehow connected Harvey let's go you remember
the night David and the others went missing David are you
still some of the visitors remember seeing strange lights in
the distance listen whatever one it's strange i feel like
i'm right next to him like i'm oh oh my god whoa whoa whoa
harvey harvey i saw him what the just happened luke the
light is the circle the light is the circle
oh so this is what happened to harvey oh he touched the
light why didn't he say anything
Siner Shemai Minto plush.
Let's go!
Thank you for getting it!
Sorry it took so long!
Two of them.
He used... Harvey used double team!
Oh, okay, here's... Okay.
Hmm.
Yeah, it did start slow, but now we're like in the thick of
it, huh?
This is craziness.
Really enjoying this battle block theater collab with
Barryman.
This already happened a year ago.
Oh my god, then they're feeding them dirt!
Hello, everybody.
Let's start today's sermon.
Yeah, what are you talking about?
Battle block?
Oh, no, this is...
What?
No, this is Minecraft.
Minecraft.
I want to play Minecraft.
I'm...
Huh?
I'm pa...
Oh.
Huh?
Hmm?
This game's freaky.
Y'all heard something?
Mm-mm.
Oh.
Oh my god, there's even grass.
Oh, man.
They can't even bury a proper...
Wait.
Victor, Ted, and Harry.
Founding members.
1956.
They look really suspicious and scary.
I hear something.
Coming from, like, in here.
Something's making a noise.
What was that, Yim?
What's that?
I have no idea what you guys are talking about.
We got the coils!
Burry me, bury me!
I hope this game ends with dancing skeletons.
I cannot even tell where it will end.
I don't know at all what's happening.
Red coil.
Green coil.
And then...
You want me to sit or...
I get it down.
Oh my god, Fred!
Oh.
Hello?
Ah!
Oh.
We got Elliot back!
Elliot!
Hey!
Are you with me?
Oh shoot.
How the hell are they doing to you?
Uh oh.
Ah!
Oh shoot, I'm going too fast.
I'm trying to find it.
I'm slow.
Oh my gosh, where's the...
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Yeah!
Take him out!
I feel like he's gonna come from one of these sides next.
Ah!
No, he's right under me.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah!
Then this side, maybe?
They come in threes?
Oh my god.
What the hell?
Yeah, first try.
Let go, please.
What just happened?
Whoa.
Oh!
Okay, we have to do this again?
Are there two at once or just one?
Sounds like it's coming from somewhere else.
Wait, is he right behind me?
Failed!
What do you mean failed?
Ah!
There's another one.
It hurts.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
This is so freaky.
Whoa!
Oh my gosh, everything is all over the place.
This is so crazy.
I'm like so focused.
This way.
No.
Oh my gosh, he's gonna get me.
Please.
Don't.
There we go.
Yeah!
Okay.
Elliot, you chill.
Yeah, I'm so locked in.
Okay.
This again.
I heard the song.
Oh my gosh.
No, no.
Please.
Don't.
Okay?
This is tense, right?
Because I can't run very fast.
So I feel nervous.
Thank you.
Oh, brother, thank you.
This is so freaky.
I got it.
Now let's get Elliot.
I picked him up.
Uh.
Excuse me.
No, don't turn it on.
Oh, this way.
Was that always here?
He's in my arms.
Elliot, I've got you.
I've got you.
You can see the sun.
Yeah.
It's...
It's a beautiful day.
Day!
Rob, you here?
I've got Elliot.
He's alive.
Just passed out.
I'm out of the caves.
I just laid Elliot down by the tree here.
Ethan, thank God we're here.
Where are they?
Coming in.
Where are you?
We're at the parking lot.
Oh, no.
Fuck.
I just gotta catch my breath.
Oh, no.
You think I see the kid.
They're rushing in to help him.
I'm... right here.
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
What do you mean, she's here, and you're where?
Wait, what do you...
What do you mean?
We're trapped in the dimensions.
We're standing at the parking lot right
now.
What?
Echo Beach finished the game.
No, we did kind of sacrifice ourselves.
Oh, he's been silent-hilled.
Oh, no!
That was crazy!
That was so cool!
Oh my gosh, that...
I almost...
The teleporting between the different areas was such a cool
trick, but it also made me like feel sick, but at the same
time, it was so cool.
I wish there was more of it, but at the same time, I'm glad
there's not more of it because it didn't make me feel like,
whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wow, that was neat, oh, that was cool.
I enjoy a good spooky sci-fi, right?
That was neat.
What do you guys think?
I wonder if there's another ending.
I wonder, too.
But yeah, I like the mystery of it, seeing it all, like,
kind of, you know, I...
Part of me is so, like, you know, I see a lot of horror
games use cults as, like, antagonists, a little overdone.
But this one felt good.
This one felt fun.
Yeah.
That was so cool.
Ooh.
I missed parts, so I kind of want to play for myself.
Yeah, you should try.
You should try.
Ooh.
Good.
Game took you by surprise.
That's good.
Needed more jump scares.
I think I'm okay with that.
More jump scares.
We were just kind of, like, in the atmosphere at all.
YouTube desyncing all night made it way immersive too.
Yeah, I thought it was pretty good.
I thought it was pretty good.
For a little indie game, right?
Yeah, this cult was rather unique.
It was pretty neat.
Cool game, cool game.
It did start pretty slow.
But...
Ended up...
Not bad.
If I continue, what happens?
Is it going to put me at that fight again?
Now let's get...
Okay, yeah.
Back to the main menu.
Pretty good, Minky Sama.
Thank you!
Any spooky series planned for October?
Besides, like, some more spooky, like, one-off games like
this, indie horror games and stuff, I do have a couple of
series that I want to do.
Gotta get through control so we can do Alan Wake.
Can you say hi to Jordan and Ryan, Minto?
Hi, she's there, yo!
Hello, Jordan and Ryan!
Hi, hi!
Spooky season opener.
Yeah, could you give you guys a little bit of a taste before
we get into some more spooky, spooky stuff?
So, hmm.
I wonder if there's more than one ending, though.
Fun little game.
Enjoy your dinner.
Maybe breakfast.
What time is it again?
For real.
Mint is actually a strawberry flavored.
Wait, am I in a time loop?
I know.
Mint has never been minty flavored.
What are you talking about?
Remember you also said dead space, right?
I do want to play dead space, yes.
I did have to push it a little bit from when I initially
wanted to start playing, but that's okay.
that I was looking up.
Oh, let's see.
Radio light endings?
I'm going to go to like discussion or anything.
No.
I want to know if there's another...
Hmm.
Sorry, I'm looking at the Reddit.
And some of the questions are so funny.
Really on the sponsored stream, 139.33, Kanoli.
Oh, thank you so much.
Go-shin-zama, Ojo-sama.
Moe-moe-boo, everybody.
Welcome to Radio Live.
We're trying out a new game.
Oh, go-in-sahimase, O-shaim-sama.
Moe-moy-boo.
Hello.
everybody welcome and welcome back to my cafe welcome
welcome um today i'm starting a new series i'm back into the
remedy verse we're trying out we're checking out control i'm
in control baby i don't really know anything about this game
so no spoilers please
where are we we're stuck in the loop!
We're stuck in the loop!
But we can get unstuck by...
Just stop eating yourself, stupid snake.
Why are you eating yourself, dumb snake?
Just stop it.
Go out and get some...
Get... get...
Something else to eat.
Eat a little brat, I don't know.
She's looping.
Oh, it's looping.
Thank you so much.
Have a good day, have a good night.
Have a good night.
Have a good time zone.
And I will see you when I see you next.
Bye bye.
Bye bye boo.
Bye.
Thank you.
See you.
Bye bye.